notre de
travailon ou je crois que c'est bon ou
vous m'entendez
ou tout d'abord merci à à tous les qu
d'être venu à nous d'avoir répondu à la
sollicitation de cette commission
d'enquête qui s'intéresse au prix de
l'électricité à court court moyen
terme
voilà mes chers collègues donc Alexandre
wiisi et François bonau ici
présent monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur nous poursuivons donc les
travaux de de cette commission avec
l'audition aujourd'hui de Monsieur
Tangui de
Bienassis qui est là vous êtes analyste
investissement énergie et climat
l'agence internationale de de l'énergie
monsieur Yve
Marignac expert énergie à l'association
negawette et Monsieur Thomas veren
directeur général économie stratégie et
finances euh chez réseau de transport
d'électricité
RTE et madame vous accompagnez monsieur
Bienassis
enchanté madame ass hein c'est bien
assis
oui bien assis on dit
moi je suis Sud-Ouest on prononce toutes
les
lettres excusez-moi euh alors cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire euh
obéit à certaines règles que je vais
vous soumettre donc avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est pas cible des peines prévu
aux articles
434-13-1- 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite à prêter cement de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure donc
pour les trois personnes voilà Monsieur
veren vous le jurez aussi très bien
c'est enregistré je vous remercie par
ailleurs aussi de de nous faire part de
vos éventuels lien
d'intérêt en rapport au au au sujet dont
nous allons
traiter le Sénat a constitué le le 18
janvier dernier une commission d'enquête
sur la réduction la consommation le prix
de l'électricité aux horizons 2035 et
2050 nos travaux donc demandés par le
groupe Union centriste euh nos travaux
seront centrés sur le présent et
l'avenir du du système électrique ce
système est-il en capacité de faire face
à la demande d'offrir au particulier à
nos entreprises une électricité à un
prix raisonnable et quelles sont ses
perspectives de développement
euh par rapport au déroulé de de
l'audition après l'écosystème de marché
que nous avons à abordé hier à
l'occasion d'une première table ronde en
ouverture de nos travaux l'objectif de
la Table Ronde d'aujourd'hui sera de
consacré aux prévisions de de
consommation prévisions à partir
desquelles les bonnes décisions en
matière de grmment du parc de production
et des réseaux de transport et de
distribution se traduisent en partie via
les marchés par des prix payés par les
différentes catégories de consommateurs
nous voudrions comprendre comment vous
bâtissez vos prévisions comment vous les
suivez et comment vous les révisez quel
niveau de de fiabilité peut-on leur
accorder vous nous direz si ce sont les
les les prévisions qui nourrissent des
scénarios des scénarios ou à l'inverse
si les prévisions sont faites pour être
cohérentes avec les 10 scénarios dans ce
cas faut-il vraiment les appeler
prévisions ne faudrait-il pas dire que
ce sont des projections euh prospectives
conforme à des scénarios souhaités ou
possibles autrement dit comment
conscilier en matière de politique
énergétique le nécessaire je pense à nos
engagements climatiques avec le possible
qui dépend de nos moyens financiers des
moyens financiers que la notion la
nation peut ou pourra y consacrer alors
nous nous vous proposons de dérouler
cette audition en en en 3 temps euh pour
chacun d'entre vous euh vous aurez 10
minutes maximum d'expression de
présentation liminaire de votre travail
de vos travaux
euh voilà on va on va vous faire
intervenir les uns après les autres tous
les trois et et ensuite on on donnera la
parole pour la prendre avant d'ailleurs
à à Monsieur le à Monsieur lepp monsieur
le rapporteur et à nos collègues ici ici
présents euh voilà qui pourront donc
s'exprimer et et vous poser des des des
questions et on terminera par un nouveau
tour de tour de table qui vous permettra
donc en rapport de à ce qui a qui aura
été dit de d'apporter des éléments
complémentaire si ce n'est si ce n'est
une conclusion de votre point de vue
voilà nous allons débuter
avec en donnant la parole à Monsieur oui
excusez-moi vas-y monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le
Président bonjour à tous ce que j'ai pas
salué en tout cas et merci merci d'être
présent effectivement alors notre
commission d'enquête elle a la
provocation de d'apporter de la clarté
sur un sujet qui est un peu nébuleux
pour pour beaucoup et qui nécessite
effectivement d'apporter des précisions
alors hier effectivement on on a
travaillé sur l'écosystème est quand
même pas mal sur la la formation du prix
hein et discussion autour de cette
formation du prix aujourd'hui on
souhaite vous entendre sur la partie
consommation alors pour certains on aura
sans doute l'occasion de vous réentendre
sur la partie réseauil y a aussi des des
enjeux pas négligeable sur la partie
réseau mais là effectivement on est on
sait que RTE a beaucoup travailler sur
ce sujet là ça veut pas dire que
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie ou
negawat n'a pas
n'a pas de d'information ou d'éléments
nous on voulait un peu challenger aussi
RTE autant le dire tout de suite sur ces
sur ces prévisions est-ce que ces
prévisions sont simplement effectivement
des déclinaisons des objectifs et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous demandera de toute
façon dans le questionnaire sans doute
de nous expliquer les variations des
prévisions sur les 10 dernières années
avec les justifications de ces
variations est-ce que ces variations
sont liées effectivement à des
changements d'objectif ou est-ce que
c'est simplement parce que on a des
comportement différents qu'on anticipe
ou des des avancées qu'on peut avoir sur
un certain nombre de de choses donc
c'est ça nous intéresse pas mal et c'est
vrai que la ces prévisions de
consommation sont importantes pour
ensuite définir les outils de production
en face à mettre en face de façon à ce
que on puisse on puisse essayer de
limiter aussi peut-être les les les
contraintes qui peuvent être apportées
sur les les
consommateurs ou au moins que ces
contraintes soient transparentes et soi
connues de tous dès le début parce que
je pense que c'est quand même le
meilleur moyen de d'obtenir une
acceptation de la part de la population
et que il ne se retrouve pas le devant
le fait accompl en disant tiens j'ai
acheté une voiture électrique et je peux
l'utiliser que 2 heures par jour donc
voilà c'est c'est c'est important pour
nous et puis la troisème partie de de
notre travail ça va être de de réfléchir
la façon dont on peut avoir des prix qui
soient moins volatiles euh sans doute
plus en rapport avec les les coûts
moyens de production et comment comment
on peut faire pour obtenir cela voilà
donc
on vous laisse effectivement vous
présenter présenter votre point de vue
en une dizaine de minutes pour que ça
soit le plus interactif possible donc on
va je pense s'abstenir de vous
interrompre pendant ces 10 minutes de
chacun et puis par contre ensuite
effectivement on essera de challenger et
vous pouvez aussi réagir par rapport à
ce que vos collègues ont pu dire
précédemment ou
ultérieur monsieur vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs donc merci de me donner
l'opportunité de m'exprimer aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet qui est important qui est
technique mais qui est au cœur de notre
débat public alors je vais ne parler que
de consommation dans mon propos pas du
mix et de son économie sont également au
cœur de nos analyses al première partie
de mon propos comment fait-on une
prévision de consommation ou une
projection de consommation d'électricité
alors déjà faire cette anticipation
c'est au cœur de notre mission celle
d'un gestionnaire du réseau national qui
doit assurer la sécurité d'alimentation
en temps réel on est obligé de bien
prévoir la consommation pour l'heure qui
vient pour le lendemain comme
l'électricité se stock pas ou se stock
mal il faut garantir à chaque instant
l'équili production consommation et
qu'on peut pas se permettre le luxe de
ne pas maîtriser la façon dont évolue la
consommation et la façon dont elle
serait susceptible d'évoluer en cas a ça
c'est très important dans notre mission
on prévoit la consommation pour la
semaine le mois qui vient souvent vous
nous entendez parler à l'entré de
l'hiver et on projette la consommation
aussi pour les années qui viennent ça ce
sont les études prévisionnelles une
mission qui est confi à RTE par la loi
comme dans les autres pays européens qui
est inscrite dans le code de l'énergie
avec ce ce nom étrange cet oxyort le
bilan
prévisionnel comment réalise-t-on ces
prévisions d'abord c'est un travail très
technique long minutieux avec beaucoup
d'expertise en réalité c'est un sujet
sur lequel la France a été pionnière
pourquoi pionnière parce que dans les
années 80 la France développe son parc
nucléaire et le chauffage électrique al
le chauffage électrique contrairement à
ce qu'on entend souvent il est pas
dominant dans le bâtiment dans le
chauffage mais il est quand même plus
important oui c'est le gaz quand même
plus important que dans d'autres pays
européens donc c'est une spécificité et
donc à cette époque il est nécessaire de
savoir comment la consommation
d'électricité va augmenter quand la
température baisse et c'est pour ça que
la France développe dans les années
80-90 des méthodes de modélisation de la
consommation qui sont très poussées par
rapport au pays voisin aujourd'hui RTE
c'est le continuateur de cette tradition
on dispose d'un modèle qui fait
référence et une expertise je pense qui
est reconnue en Europe alors c'est un
travail central parce que ça nous permet
de dire quand la consommation baisse ou
qu'elle augmente est-ce que c'est lié à
la température conditions extérieure ou
est-ce que c'est lié à un changement des
comportements et ça ça a été important
de bien le savoir lorsqu'on était dans
la crise de l'hiver 2022
2023 pour projeter la consommation dans
l'avenir que ce soit un avenir proche ou
un avenir lointain il y a toujours deux
étapes première étape on calcule les
volumes annuels d'électricité à
température normale là on intgre
toujours quatre types de paramètres la
projection macroéconomique la population
le PIB les échanges internationaux la
projection de la performance des
équipements ça c'est très technique très
concret nombre de
réfrigérateurs nombre de fours de pompe
à chaleur quelle est leur classe
technique ça fait partie du travail
c'est une partie importante la
projection des habitudes et des modes de
vie part de l'habitat individuel par
rapport au collectif déplacement
collectif ou déplacement en voiture
individuelle et projection du rythme de
décarbonation donc des transferts
d'usage entre le gaz le pétrole et
l'électricité sur chacun de ces sujets
on a des experts qui tiennent à jour
toute une littérature technique qui
compare entre prévision et réalisé et
qui compare avec d'autres pays et on
croise des orientations publique des
choix industriels et des choix sociétaux
une fois qu'on a ça on a fait la partie
la plus simple du travail la seconde
c'est d'entirer une vision heure par
heure en fonction de la météo et de
l'évolution du climat futur c'est la
partie la plus sensible c'est cette
partie là que va dépendre la sécurité
d'alimentation et c'est la partie qui
prend le plus de temps puisque pour
chaque heure dans 15 ans il va falloir
qu'on compare la production et la
consommation
prévisionnelle en fonction du vent de la
pluie de la
température de la réverbération des
aléas techniques possible sur le parc de
production ces données météorologiques
on a un partenariat stratégique avec
Météo France pour les fournir et puis on
intègre j'en suis très fier parce qu'on
a été les premiers en Europe à le faire
le changement climatique en intégrant
les scénarios du JEC dans notre
prévision dans notre prévision de la
consommation donc ça c'est c'était ma
première partie comment comment on fait
une prévision donc maintenant ce qui a
fait débat ces dernières années les
projections à moyen long terme alors
tout d'abord oui ces prévisions ces
projections vous verrez qu'on fait les
deux pour répondre à votre consommation
elles évoluent avec le temps parce que
la vision qu'on a de notre avenir évolue
et également parce que le dispositif a
évolué pour pouvoir répondre à des
nouvelles questions à des questions que
se posaent la collectivité alors bref
récapitulative je prends une profondeur
de champ d'une 20 25 ans année 2000
première période à cette époque la
consommation d'électricité augmentait en
volume et en pointe annuelle elle
augmentait parce que croissance
économique plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
parce que développement des usages
électriques à cette période le chauffage
le numérique et parce que peu de progrès
d'efficacité électrique parce que
l'électricité notamment étant très très
bon marché il y avait peu de peu d'effet
de rétroaction à cette époque les
prévisionistes pensait plutôt que
l'électricité continuerait de croître de
manière assez linéaire peut-être moins
qu'avant mais quand même de croître ils
ont plutôt eu tort la consommation a
cessé d'augmenter à peu près à à la
crise financière de 2008 un petit peu
après deuxème période les années 2010 là
on a une consommation dont on voit
qu'elle se met à stagner voire à baisser
c'est vrai en France c'est vrai aussi
dans d'autres pays européens pourquoi
ralentissement de la croissance et
notamment
désindustrialisation développement de
l'électricité qui qui ralentit beaucoup
notamment c'est le gaz qui est bon
marché à l'époque qui est promu dans le
secteur du bâtiment et puis l'efficacité
électrique progresse elle un
réfrigérateur performant aujourd'hui je
je parle fréquemment de réfrigérateur
c'est 45 % d'économie d'énergie par
rapport au parc moyen de réfrigérateur
remplacer nos ordinateurs fixes des
années 2000 avec la grosse tour par
rapport avec des ordinateurs portables
c'est un facteur 5 d'économie d'énergie
donc tout ça ça s'est développé beaucoup
dans les années 200020 à l'époque les
politiques publiques en plus sont pas
spécialement porté vers
l'électrification ni dans le transport
véhiculle électrique balbuciant ni dans
le bâtiment j'ai parlé du gaz et de la
réglementation thermique de 2012 ni dans
l'industrie donc les prévisions de RTE
pour le moyen terme elles en témoignent
elles deviennent stabl ou baissière et
aujourd'hui on est 10 ans après on peut
comparer la consommation réelle cité à
la consommation projetée est-ce qu'elles
étaient justes bien oui la consommation
d'électricité a baissé elle a baissé de
manière même importante et elle avait
commencé à baisser avant la crise
énergétique donc les prévisionnistes de
l'époque qui pensaient que la
consommation baisserait ont eu plutôt
raison par rapport à l'avenir à 5 100
ans 3è époque la fin des années 2010 et
le début des années 2020 donc là la
question c'est la préparation de la
neutralité carbone en 2050 qui devient
l'objectif de notre politique ce ce qui
n'était pas dans les années 2010 là la
France se pose un certain de grandes
questions sur les principales options
qui sont devant elles le nucléaire
est-ce qu'on renouvelle ou pas les
énergies renouvelable la
réindustrialisation la sobriété
l'hydrogène donc pour étudier ce sujet
il faut plus qu'une vision
prévisionnelle à court terme il faut une
projection à long terme de ce que serait
la consommation d'électricité dans un
monde neutre en carbone et donc ce
travail nous l'avons fait nous l'avons
fait de manière technique méthodique et
concertée technique parce que ce qui
compte c'est pas de ça sa voir combien
qu'on va consommer un véhicule
électrique c'est comment va se comporter
un parc de 18 millions de véhicules
électriques en
2035 méthodique parce que nous avons
analysé progressivement les trois grands
secteurs à transfert d'usage les
transports avec le véhicule électrique
l'industrie avec l'hydrogène le bâtiment
avec la perspective de déployer des
pompes à chaleur et concerté parce que
tous nos choix ont été fait de manière
publique on a analysé une centaine de
scénarios de variantes et de stress test
on a analysé des scénarios sobri était à
au moment où le mot était pas encore
complètement à la mode et des scénarios
de réindustrialisation profonde alors
qu'on nous traitait de dou rever donc en
fait différentes options on les a
analysé et tout ça est traduit écrit
documenté et ça c'est ce qui a donné
notre étude qui s'appelle les futurs
énergétique 2050 et qui date de 2021 que
disent ces analyses sur la consommation
d'électricité que même si la France
parvient et c'est souhaitable à réduire
sa consommation d'énergie la
consommation d'électricité elle va
augmenter et ça c'est la contrepartie de
la sortie des énergies fossiles parce
qu'en France même si on adore discuter
des renouvelables et du nucléaire 60 %
de l'énergie qu'on consomme c'est du
pétrole et du gaz c'est bien ces 60 %
qui sont la source de nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre une source
importante de notre déséquipe
commerciale et à mon sens le problème
majeur de souveraineté énergétique parce
que à contrario l'électricité on peut la
produire sur notre territoire donc notre
analyse c'est que même si on est sobre
même si on réussit à bien rénover nos
logements et même s'il y a d'autres
énergies bas carbone que l'électricité
sortir des énergies fossiles va
mécaniquement faire augmenter nos
besoins d'électricité donc les
trajectoires que l'on publie dans ces
projections sont croissantes cohérentes
je pense avec celle de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie ou celles
qui sont faites sous l'égide de la
Commission européenne et elles sont
d'autant plus croissantes que la France
voudra atteindre en 2030 des objectifs
qu'elle s'est fixé qui sont très
ambitieux le feed for 55 réduire les
émissions de 55 % N
et réussir la réindustrialisation et la
décarbonation alors dernière partie de
mon propos est-ce que c'est crédible
est-ce qu'on est certain de ces
trajectoire objectivement il existe
aujourd'hui une incertitude sur
l'ampleur de cette augmentation et sur
son timing c'est la raison pour laquelle
RTE produit pas uniquement des scénarios
où on atteint les objectifs publics nous
publions également des scénarios de
retard et des scénarios de crise
prolongée qu'on a appelé mondialisation
contrariée sont pas des scénarios qui
sont souhaitables mais c'est aussi notre
responsabilité d'entreprise de service
public que de publier ces scénarios et
de voir comment on se confronterait à
ces mondesl donc sans rentrer dans le
détail de ces scénari on voit bien que
pour que la consommation
d'électricité évolue comme on le dit
dans les scénarios d'atteint des
objectifs il y a trois grands défis un
défi sur le rythme de déploiement des
équipements B carbone al notamment sur
l'industrie hein par qu'on veut à la
fois décarboner l'industrie qui existe
c'est l'exemple des haut fourneaux à
dkererc et attirer sur le territoire des
nouvelles installations not pour
produire des batteries bon ben ça ça
dépendra du prix de
l'électricité hydrogène il y a un gros
défi sur hydrogène parce qu'en fait
l'hydrogène c'est ce qui consomme le
plus d'électricité dans l' dans les
perspectives d'augmentation c'est pas la
voiture électrique c'est pas le bâtiment
la pompe à chaleur qui conduit notre
consommation d'électricité à augmenter
le plus si on suit la stratégie
française c'est la production
d'hydrogène production d'hydrogène elle
dépendra également des conditions
d'approvisionnement en électricité deuxè
défi les l'évolution des modes de vie
donc on sait maintenant que la
consommation en temps de crise elle peut
baisser de manière assez
spectaculaire la question c'est de
savoir ce qui est pérenne dans cette
diminution on pense qu'une partie de ce
qui est la chasse au gaspill peut être
assez largement prolongée à les uncan
plus loin en matière de
sobriété ce qu'on appelle la sobriété
structurelle c'est des transformations
dans l'aménagement de notre territoire
et dans les modes de vie qui sont quand
même d'une autre ampleur et dernier défi
la consommation repose son évolution
repose sur la matérialisation de gain
d'efficacité énergétique là il y a ce
dont personne ne parle jamais mais qui
fonctionne assez bien la progression de
l'efficacité électrique dans les dans
les appareils alors on n parle pas parce
qu'en fait ça progresse il y a les gains
qui vont résulter de notre politique de
décarbonation un véhicule électrique ça
consomme trois fois moins d'énergie
qu'un véhicule thermique pareil pour une
pompe à chaleur face à une chaudière au
fiel et puis il y a le sujet sur lequel
il y a objectivement un point
d'interrogation le rythme de rénovation
des logements on est prudent sur ce
sujet on intègre un effet rebond parce
qu'on sait que on peut pas modéliser la
consommation d'électricité des bâtiment
uniquement en fonction de leur classe
énergétique ce qui compte c'est le
budget chauffage des des Français et ça
ça joue un rôle très important dans la
modélisation j'en arrive à ma conclusion
premièrement d'un point de vue factuel
la consommation d'électricité au cours
de ces dernières années elle na jamais
été supérieur à ce qui figurait dans nos
scénarios donc on n' pas sousdimensionné
la consommation je dirais que
malheureusement on avait vu juste à
plusieurs reprises ce qui a montré
l'évolution de notre consommation
d'électricité ces dernières années c'est
que la France se désindustrialisait et
c'est que l'électricité c'était que un
gros quart de notre consommation
d'énergie alors que les fossiles c'était
2/ers deuxièmement maintenant je pense
vraiment que la perspective c'est de se
préparer à des augmentations importantes
de la consommation d'électricité si l'on
parvient à enclencher la sortie des
énergies fossile sur l'ampleur sur le
point d'inflexion les questions sont
ouvertes à court terme il y a il y a pas
de signal évident en matière de pure
prévision d'une augmentation très rapide
de la consommation d'électricité c'est
une projection pour atteindre un certain
nombre d'objectifs
troisièmement je pense que c'est logique
qu'il y ait encore un débat ouvert sur
le volume d'électricité à long terme
parce qu'en fait ça dépend de la France
qu'on projette en 2050 et donc là selon
je dire objectivement rien n'est joué
par rapport à ça nous c'est notre
mission légale de documenter les
différents scénarios quand on en
documente un ça veut pas dire qu'on le
préfère par rapport à un autre on a un
dispositif ouvert de concertation c'est
vrai aussi sur le mix électrique avec le
nucléaire et les renouvelables donc on
effectue ces travaux en transparence a
priori dans la concertation à postériori
parce qu'on documente tout de manière
assez maniaque ça fait que les rapports
sont assez volumineux tout le monde a
accès à ces scénarios et nous pouvons
tester les scénarios qui nous sont
demandés par les représentants du peuple
il n'y a aucun problème je l'ai déjà dit
lors de différents différentes auditions
dernièrement bah les projections de
consommation c'est un produit technique
il peut arriver quand même dans le débat
qu'elle soit des fois un peu déformée
caricaturé
euh parfois en fonction de l'agenda de
certains groupes qui de pression qui
utiliseent ceses ces projections avec
mes équipes d'ingénieurs et de
spécialistes on essaie d'y résister en
livrant une expertise documentée et donc
nécessairement nuancée donc c'est un peu
un c'est un combat d'essayer toujours de
documenter ça à fond de montrer les
différentes options on essaie de le
faire en par notre étude 2021 je pense
qu'on a montré qu'on était en capacité
de dépolitiser quand même une partie des
débats et d'avoir pendant 2 ans de
manière technique un grand nombre
d'acteurs qui travaillent sur un produit
technique ensuite les grandes options
elles sont pour pour la discussion
publique c'est ça notre objectif donc
moi je suis persuadé qu'au-delà des des
postures c'est un travail qui a permis
que a des un socle de conviction
technique en fait ces solutions
techniques elles sont sur la fin et j'en
termine monsieur le Président sur ce
qu'on a dit sur notre bilan prévisionnel
les quatre piliers l'efficacité la
sobriété le nucléaire et notamment la
production des réacteurs actuels et le
développement des renouvelables et en
réalité je pense qu'entre les experts
aujourd'hui c'est une question de dosage
entre les différents niveaux mais que il
y a beaucoup de points communs merci
beaucoup merci monsieur vering je donne
la parole à Monsieur Bienassis bienass
pardon pardon merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs mesdames et messieurs
merci de d'avoir invité l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie à présenter
aujourd'hui alors je dans ma dans mon
propos je vais beaucoup illustrer ce qui
a été dit avant puisqu'on est on on
s'inscrit à peu près dans la même dans
dans les mêmes messages juste un petit
un petit rappel sur ce qu'est l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie c'est une
agence qui a été créée en 1974 à la
suite du premier choc pétrolier et dont
le la mission originelle était d'assurer
la sécurité d'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial et de favoriser la
coopération entre ces pays membres et
aujourd'hui cette mission reste à peu
près la même on a juste incorporé une
dimension supplémentaire qui est le
développement durable et on utilise donc
nos analyses pour informer et
accompagner nos gouvernements et les
autres parties prenantes sur les grands
enjeux du secteur énergétique et
climatique afin
d' de afin de d'élaborer un système qui
soit sûr et abordable donc je pense que
c'est important de le rappeler pour
cette pour cette commission nous sommes
environ 300 à Paris euh donc les
analyses de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie sont regroupées dans notre
rapport annuel le World Energy Outlook
qui utilise donc des les données
disponibles pour analyser les tendances
du système énergétique les émissions
associées et les impacts sur
l'environnement sur le climat mais aussi
qui transcrit les scénarios dont je vais
parler tout à l'heure en terme de
d'investissement et et autres métriques
euh on on utilise trois scénarios dans
cette publication dont je vais euh vite
donner un un un une rapide vue le
premier scénario que nous utilisons
c'est le celui qu'on appelle les
politiques existantes ou steps qui prend
en compte toutes les politiques
énergétiques qui sont actuellement en
place et qui analysent où celles-ci nous
mènent c'est un peu si vous voulez le
scénario de de référence ou le le
business as usual comme on dirait en bon
français et il est important de préciser
que ce scénario ne prend en compte que
les lois et les régulations qui existent
déjà qui sont déjà dans le qui sont déjà
implémenté euh en cela il est donc très
différent de notre deuxième scénario qui
lui va regarder les engagements annoncés
des pays ou des ou des entreprises quand
on parle d'engagement annoncé ça veut
dire quand un pays annonce un objectif
de neutralité carbone à un certain
horizon 2050 ou après on va prendre cet
engagement pour argent comptant et on va
l'intégrer dans nos scénarios on va
compiler tout ça au niveau mondial et
regarder où ça nous mène il est très
important de savoir que pour ce scénario
il n'y a aucun aucune critique qui est
qui est est appliqué pour savoir pour
essayer de de de voir si ce scénario est
faisable ou non on prend vraiment les
engagements pour argent comptant
euh le trisème scénario qui est un peu
différent des des deux autres puisquil
il lui il établit un objectif final donc
le maintien du réchauffement climatique
en dessous de 1 der5 et il déroule
ensuite les
hypothèses et donc c'est notre c'est le
scénario qui a atteint la neutralité
carbone en 2050 dans le dans le système
énergétique
au niveau global et
donc autre petite précision
méthodologique aussi cette fois
géographique les scénarios de la sont
élaborés via des grandes régions mais
sont élaborés au niveau
mondial et donc on a on a on n'élabore
pas de scénarioos précis concernant la
France on a juste des données pour une
une grande région qu'on appelle European
Union a et qui comprend la France
l'Allemagne et l'Italie
alors si vous me permettez de commencer
par un bref exposé de la demande
électrique mondiale ce qu'on observe et
ce qui a déjà été dit par Thomas c'est
que elle augmente constamment et depuis
depuis les années 2000 et elle est
fortément corrélé à la démographie et à
la croissance du PIB dans dans le monde
et elle a augmenté en moyenne de 3 %
depuis depuis le début des anné 2000 je
fais une petite parenthèse je suis allé
chercher dans les dans les tiroirs de
dans dans nos bureaux pour retrouver le
plus vieux rapport que je pouvais
trouver donc j'ai retrouvé celui de
1994 donc 30 ans et j'ai essayé de
regarder ce qu'on disait à l'époque sur
les sur nos projections de demande
électrique et on voit qu'on était un
petit peu supérieur environ 10 %
supérieur sur ce qu'on se disait sur sur
la la la consommation qu'on qu'on
anticipait pour les années 2000 et 2010
euh si on regarde maintenant les
projections de demande à 2050 donc dans
le dans le scénario steps qui encore une
fois le scénario un peu de référence qui
qui qui utilise les les lois et les
régulations qui sont déjà en place on
voit queon a une continuation de la
tendance globale et une demande
d'électricité qui croit d'environ 2 %
par an pour venir s'établir aux
alentours de 46000 tawh par an
2050 si on regarde j'ai j'ai aussi fait
la comparaison avec d'autres rapports
qu'on avait fait donc en 2020 2015 et
2010 et on est à peu près consistant
dans les dans dans dans dans dans ces
rapports si regarde maintenant donc
l'autre scénario celui qui prend en
compte les engagements annoncés donc les
les toutes les annonces des pays
concernant leur neutralité carbone on
voit une une augmentation une croissance
de la demande électrique beaucoup plus
forte et qui s'explique ben par des des
politiques d'électrification beaucoup
plus ambitieuses et donc dans ce
scénario on a une demande qui croit de 3
% par an en moyenne entre 2022 et 2050
et qui s'établit autour de 57000 TWh par
an et si on prend maintenant le troisème
scénario donc qui est celui qui atteint
la neutralité carbone en 2050 la demande
totale atteint 64000 tawh par an et donc
on on arrive euh c'est une une
croissance de 4 % par an de la demande
électrique
euh je sais plus où j'en suis en temps
mais euh alors c'est vrai qu' un point
de un point de pourcentage peut paraître
pas pas beaucoup dans les dans les dans
l'augmentation mais quand vous vous vous
le tirez jusqu'à 2050 ça nous donne une
demande qui est de 23 % supérieur dans
laaps et 40 % de plus dans le dans le
net Z0 comparé au aux steps euh de de la
même année si maintenant on regarde au
niveau européen si on regarde les mêmes
données ce qu'on constate depuis des
années 2000 et ce que Thomas a déjà dit
c'est en gros une une relative
stagnation de la demande électrique et
même même une une décroissance dans pour
les les quelques dernières années euh et
on voit que la la consommation
électrique pour cette région encore une
fois c'est cette région qui regroupe les
trois pays France Allemagne Italie la
consommation électrique c'est s'établie
environ à 1200 TWh et alors la même
chose que tout à l'heure si on regarde
ge les les différents scénarios on
constate qu'une demande d'électrique qui
est de l'ordre de 60 % plus importante
en 2050 qu'aujourd'hui dans le scénario
steps et 75 % dans le scénario aps euh
on montre pas le net z0ro ici parce que
déjà on on on na pas forcément fait le
la modélisation dans tous les pays pour
le net zéro et aussi pour l'Europe on
considère que les annonces de politiques
qui ont été fait par l'Europe sont
compatibles avec une trajectoire net
zéro si elles sont implémentées bien sûr
euh donc c'est pour ça qu'on montre que
que la PS sur sur ce sur ce diapositive
et donc ces trajectoires euh illustrent
bien sûr une part grandissante de
l'électricité dans la consommation
d'énergie finale comme comme Thomas l'a
dit si on regarde aujourd'hui
l'électricité représente environ 20 % de
l'énergie finale total dans dans la
région qui nous intéresse et d'ici 2050
cette part passe passe à à 60
%.
euh et même même si on si on touche à
rien si on continue sur la trajectoire
actuelle donc matérialisé par le steps
on passe à une électricité qui
représente 40 % de l'énergie finale
totale et si on regarde maintenant ce
qui explique cette cette
augmentation on voit une forte
électrification des usages et notamment
dans le dans le transport par exemple
dans les voitures électriques et c'est
le transport à lui presque à lui seul
explique une grande part de
l'augmentation de la demande dans notre
dans notre scénario alors on a des
petites différences dans les suivant les
scénarios dans le transport par exemple
on peut avoir des des ambitions plus
fortes dans dans l'électrification des
du des des camions par exemple et du
transport de la
logistique cette électrification de la
mobilité est principalement induite par
la mise en place de politiques
ambitieuses au niveau de l'Union
européenne comme l'interdiction de la
vente des voitures thermiques d'ici à
2035 on voit d'autres aspects
l'électrification notamment dans les
bâtiments Thomas en a parlé tout à
l'heure le l'électrification du
chauffage via les pompes à chaleur euh
et et mais on voit une comme Thomas en a
parlé aussi on voit une une augmentation
un peu moindre justement dans dans les
bâtiments et c'est notamment dû au
progrès d'efficacité énergétique et
d'efficacité électrique qui viennent
compenser pour partie l'augmentation il
y a aussi une augmentation importante
dans l'industrie avec l'électrification
de procédés industriels qui reposaient
àaravant auparavant sur des combustibles
fossiles comme par exemple les pompes à
chaleur à haute température les arcs
électriques et les choses comme ça nos
projections comportent une grande part
d'incertitude sur certains aspects
notamment la la rapidité du
développement de des différentes
technologies l'électrification mais
aussi sur la sur l'hydrogène c'est c'est
une des grandes incertitudes de notre
scénario
quelle quelle proportion de de
développement de l'hydrogène et et à
quel quel terme on a aussi la
contribution par exemple des des des des
centres des Data Center les les choses
comme ça qui qui qui peuvent ajouter à
l'incertitude en tout cas si on regarde
au niveau européen on note un vrai
changement des politiques qui vont
accélérer cette cette électrification le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
qui a eu un effet majeur sur le
développement des politique en matière
d'énergie et l'accent qui a été mis par
l'Europe sur sur les politiques de
sécurité
énergétique on voit notamment les toutes
les toutes les réglementations qui ont
été mises en place pour le la fin du
véhicule thermique et les soutiens en
politique de rénovation du parc
immobilier qui sont à la base de cette
vague d'électrification donc en
conclusion je me permettrais juste
d'ajouter que malgré ce fort potentiel
d'électrification qui est indéniable
Thomas en a parlé aussi tout à l'heure
les projections vont souvent avoir
tendance à être un tout petit peu
surestimé et ce pour pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est bien sûr une
raison de de sécurité
d'approvisionnement on est tous les
énergéticiens et toutes les les les
bureaux d'études comme nous ont pour
rôle de d'assurer et de d'informer le
bon dimensionnement des moyens de
production et de distribution et on va
donc naturellement préférer donner des
estimations un tout petit peu plus
hautes surtout que les investissements
qui doivent être fait très en amont une
erreur une sousestimation peut être très
préjudiciable
euh et avec un sousdimensionnement
sousdimensionnement du système et
l'incapacité de répondre à la demande
alors bien sûr si on regarde les
projections qui étaient faites avant les
chocs pétroliers on avait parlé de des
projections qui avaient été faites dans
les années 50 elle prenait probablement
des hypothèses de croissance du PIB qui
était celle qui était à l'époque donc
très très forte mais c'est plus du tout
le cas aujourd'hui et donc on est on est
beaucoup plus conservateur dans nos dans
dans nos dans nos dans nos prévisions on
a
[Musique]
aussi il est difficile de modéliser les
gains d'efficacité énergétique et
d'efficacité électrique à long terme on
a parlé par exemple des des des des
frigidaires mais on peut on peut par
exemple se rappeler de la la très rapide
implémentation de l'éclairage LED qui
était très difficile de voir il y a
quelques années euh et donc ça vient
réduire la demande électrique pour un
même niveau de service et ce qui peut
être peut être difficile d'anticiper ces
ces ces progrès technologique à long
terme et il existe aussi bien sûr dans
nos dans nos projections c'est ces
incertitudes dont j'avais parlé
précédemment donc la vitesse de
déploiement des véhicules électriquees
de rénovation des bâtiments euh et le
développement de l'hydrogène et des des
des autres besoins associés merci
beaucoup merci
monsieur je donne la parole à Monsieur
Marignac pour ngawat merci merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et et sénateurs c'est
évidemment un plaisir de venir vous
apporter un éclairage complémentaire à
ce qui vient d'être dit que pour une
très grande partie je je rejoins et
Thomas verin l'a dit il y a beaucoup de
convergence aujourd'hui entre les les
différents scénarios et les exercices
prospectifs je pense que c'est important
de le souligner euh vous connaissez sans
doute l'association negawat qui est
connu pour ces scénarios fondés sur une
approche basée sur la maîtrise de la
demande la sobriété et l'efficacité et
je crois qu'on a été pionnier à porter
ce terme de sobriété bien bien avant
qu'il soit qu'il soit à la mode je
voudrais revenir sur l'importance que ça
a pour nous et en commençant peut-être
par revenir sur cette dimension
historique qu' a donné déjà un peu un
peu Thomas verin pour souligner que
historiquement quand on remonte aux
années an 70 80 en particulier les
projections sur la consommation
d'électricité ont été beaucoup plus
utilisées comme des prédiction pour
piloter les politiques sur l'offre que
comme un instrument de pilotage de
politique de maîtrise de la demande si
on remonte loin aux années 70 voire 80
il y avait une règle d'or énoncé par EDF
qui dominait la capacité de scénario à
l'époque et qui disait la la
consommation d'électricité doublera tous
les 10 an ça ne s'est évidemment pas
matérialisé loin sans faux mais ça a
servi au départ de dimensionnement au
développement de notre nouveau système
de de production électrique dans dans
ces années-là plus près de nous Henry
progliot quand François Hollande annonce
son engagement de réduire la part du
nucléaire dans la production
électrique répond que en fait il y a pas
besoin de le faire parce que la
consommation d'électricité va être
multipliée par 1,5 d'ici 2025 on est en
2023 elle a plutôt baissé de 5 % par
rapport à 2012 qu'augmenté mais c'est
c'était quelque chose de de récurrent et
Thomas a eu vraiment raison de rappeler
à quel point les évolutions tracées par
le le le le les les bilans prévisionnels
au fil du temps ont marqué ce changement
en fait de nature des exercices avec des
exercices qui ont longtemps suivi
une une projection qui s'écrasé de plus
en plus jusqu'à passer comme il l'a dit
dit en 2017 par une projection en légère
baisse de la consommation et qui sont
remonté très récemment il faut souligner
que à l'époque en 2017 RTE euh insistait
sur le fait que cette baisse légère qui
était le fait que les politiques
d'efficacité en place même s'il n'était
pas très volontariste apportaiit plus de
réduction de la consommation que les
effets à la hausse de la croissance
démographique économique et des
transferts d'usage RTE soulignait que
c'était une bonne chose du point de vue
de la maîtrise de l'équilibre du système
électrique et de la maîtrise des coûts
de son fonctionnement et des des des
besoins d'équipement et c'est une leçon
qu'il faut garder aujourd'hui où parce
que le paradigme de construction de ces
projections a changé on se projette dans
une forte augmentation et je je
reviendrai dans un instant sur ce sur ce
point mais effectivement le paradigme a
changé parce que ça a déjà été dit
aujourd'hui tous les scénarios ou
l'essentiel des scénarios sont
construits autour d'impératifs à long
terme notamment la neutralité carbone ce
qui veut dire deux choses ce qui veut
dire d'abord d'inscrire ses réflexions
sur l'électricité dans une vision
portant sur non seulement l'ensemble du
système énergétique mais même l'ensemble
de l'économie et ce qui veut dire y
introduire effectivement des projections
qui ne sont plus de la prévision mais
des projections de nature normative
sur les moyens en fait qui qui doivent
éclairer les moyens à mettre en œuvre
pour atteindre ces objectifs alors sur
le premier point je voudrais souligner
que en en insistant sur l'extrême
qualité effectivement de la modélisation
que développe RTE et l'extrême rigueur
méthodologique avec laquelle elle est
faite et le sérieux que RTE applique à
la concertation donc ça veut dire que
les exercices sont vraiment robustes
sous cet angle mais le revers de la
médaille c'est que RTE aujourd'hui et
projette des scénarios pour
l'électricité qui cherch à atteindre un
objectif qui qui qui porte en fait sur
un périmètre plus large que la
modélisation et ce qui induit que RTE
effectivement par construction est amené
à explorer avant tout le levier de
l'électrification et je le je le dis ici
parce que je voudrais qu même mentionner
qu'il y a d'autres scénarios dans le
paysage qui sont basés sur une
modélisation moins fine sur
l'électricité mais couvrant l'ensemble
du périmètre et qui explore d'autres
équilibres entre les leviers nécessaires
pour la décarbonation l'électrification
oui mais plus de sobriété et ou plus
d'efficacité et ou plus de recours aux
énergies renouvelables ou de changement
des pratiques agricoles et forestières
pour renforcer les puits naturels de de
carbone c'est illustré notamment je vous
donne juste ce ce chiffre pour éclairer
la la discussion par les travaux de
l'ADEM qui a publié quatre scénarios où
la consommation d'électricité en
2050 varie entre un peu plus de 300 TWh
et 700 TWh et par ailleurs l'exercice
Adem tant à montrer que les scénarios où
la consommation d'électricité est plus
is qui sont les scénarios qui mettent
plus en œuvre la sobriété et
l'efficacité par ailleurs sont aussi
ceux où la neutralité carbone est
atteinte avec le plus de marge ou de
confiance et les scénarios qui
présentent le plus de résilience donc
c'est voilà des enseignement à à prendre
en
compte et ça m'amène à la question
suivante qui est celle de la confiance
que l'on peut avoir aujourd'hui dans ces
différentes
projections à caractère à caractère
normatif
euh je l'ai je l'ai déjà dit he on a
changé vraiment d'univers on est passé
en 20 ans d'un monde où on faisait
plutôt des scénarios de prévision des
scénarios tendantiels et cetera un monde
où on a comparé ces scénarios business
as usual avec des scénario plus
ambitieux c'est d'une certaine manière
ce que fait encore laie parce que elle
regarde les les les politiques
nationales en place mais on est même en
train de basculer vers un monde où on ne
regarde plus que des scénarios normatifs
par rapport aux objectifs à long terme
tel que tel que la neutralité carbone et
dans ce contexte là c'est important de
mesurer à quel point l'ensemble des
acteurs tend spontanément à faire plus
confiance à des projectionction d'autant
plus qu'elles sont volontaristes du côté
de l'offre que du côté de la demande à
contrario même du retour d'expérience
parfois parce que je vous rappelle par
exemple que la France est en retard sur
ses objectifs de d'énergie R
renouvelable connaît des difficultés euh
du côté de sa trajectoire nucléaire et
qu'à l'inverse on sait là aussi ça a été
rappelé que des dispositifs de de de
maîtrise de la demande d'efficacité
énergétique comme l'étiquette énergie
sur les appareils électroménagés
produisent des effets que l'on anticipe
assez bien du point de vue de de
l'efficacité et de l'impact sur sur la
consommation et donc voilà c'est
essentiel pour nous aujourd'hui de
considérer des politiques ambitieuses
sur la demande on l'a déjà fait des
politiques ambitieuses sur la demande
mais pas pour en France mais pas pour
soutenir une baisse pour soutenir une
hausse c'est là aussi ce que Thomas
verin a rappelé hein c'est la politique
de développement du chauffage électrique
avec des effets qui aujourd'hui et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je le mentionne
sont assez structurants là aussi sur la
manière dont on peut piloter le système
électrique avec cet effet de pointe
hivernale lié au aux périodes de froid
où il arrive que la pointe dépasse 90 GW
de puissance appel avec environ 30 GW
dans ces périodes de pointe qui sont
liés au chauffage électrique lui-même
euh et donc la question aujourd'hui
c'est comment on peut projeter des
trajectoires plus ambitieuses alors je
vais pas vous détailler euh le contenu
des des hypothèses de de negaw mais je
voudrais simplement le résumer en disant
que peut-être la particularité de notre
scénario c'est effectivement d'envisager
en cohérence avec toutes les autres
trajectoire une forte augmentation des
services rendus par l'électricité donc
une électrification au sens des usages
auquel on répond mais qui ne va pas
forcément de paire avec une augmentation
de la consommation d'électricité dans la
mesure où l'efficacité d'une part et la
sobriété qui permet d'éliminer des
usages électriques ne rendant pas
véritablement de service permet un
certain découplage entre les deux
facteurs et ça se traduit dans le
scénario negaw par une forte
augmentation de l'électricité dans le
chauffage par exemple on atteint 60 % de
logement chauffé mais avec des pompes à
chaleur installé dans des bâtiments bien
rénovés et donc il y a un enjeu
d'efficacité énorme au passage notre
analyse c'est que si on ne rénove pas
les bâtiments dans lesquels on installe
des pompes à chaleur on risque
d'augmenter de euh 7 8 10 % la pointe
électrique associée au au passage
hivernal euh on a évidemment une
électrification de la mobilité une
électrification un doublement à peu près
des des des procédés s'appuyant sur
l'électricité dans dans l'industrie et
tout ça euh contribue à une part de
l'électricité qui approche 50 % de de
nos besoins énergétiques mais avec une
baisse de la demande électrique de 10 %
hors augmentation pour pour les besoins
en hydrogène qui situent notre scénario
autour de 550 TWh au total en en 2050
voilà et donc cette évolution qui se
traduit pour nous par un une une voilà
quelque chose de compatible avec le
maintien d'un ha niveau de service
compatible avec une réindustrialisation
avec de la création d'emplois et avec de
multiples cobénéfices la question
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement comment
on se donne confiance beaucoup plus que
historiquement dans ce type de de de
trajectoire mais je finirai par un point
qui est le caractère absolument
nécessaire de le faire de notre point de
vue parce que là je reviens aux
projections de RTE ou au projection de
la du projet de PPE présenté par le
gouvernement on est sur pratiquement 15
tawh d'augmentation des besoins
électriques au rythme annuel jusqu'à
2030- 2035 et c'est clairement un rythme
que des moyens des nouveaux moyens de
production décarbonés ne pourront pas
suivre au-delà on peut en discuter parce
que on peut activer des leviers plus
plus profonds mais à cette échéance on
n'y parviendra pas et donc il est
nécessaire en fait la la condition
nécessaire de la réussite des objectifs
d'électrification et de
réindustrialisation qui sont au cœur de
la neutralité carbone et de la
compétitivité et de la souveraineté
passe par une accélération de la
sobriété et de l'efficacité et on pense
que le scénario negawat et d'autres
apporte beaucoup d'éléments aujourd'hui
pour se donner confiance pour aller dans
ce sens
merci merci Monsieur Marignac je je
passe la parole à à monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vos exposés qui sont
effectivement bien instructifs euh même
si le dernier est un peu en opposition
avec les les précédents parce que les
scénarios negawat donc si j'ai bien
compris hein vont vont dans le sens euh
d'une baisse quand même de la
consommation électrique ou alors j'ai
pas bien compris parce que même si
l'électricité prend une part plus
importante euh la baisse euh de
consommation énergétique totale hein
c'est bien ce que j'ai compris dans ce
que vous avez dit euh vous iriez plutôt
vers une baisse de de 10 % de la la
consommation électrique euh et laad
laadem est dans ce parce qu'on les a pas
invité ça peut on peut regretter les pas
les avoir invités mais je pense qu'ils
seront invités à d'autres euh d'autres
table ronde vont dans votre sens ù il y
a certains scénarios en tout cas de LAM
attendez je vais reposer les questions
vous pouvez répondre à
[Musique]
celle-là si si je peux répondre du tac
au tac alors les scénarios de laadem
exploreent vraiment des des options qui
vont de d'un d'une activation nettement
plus forte que dans le scénario ngaw de
levier de sobriété et d'efficacité ils
appellent ça la frugalité et c'est ça
qui amène à 300 TWh donc
une réduction d'un/ à peu près d'un/ par
rapport à aujourd'hui à des scénarios où
on monte à 700 TWh qui sont assez proche
du dans dans dans les niveaux en tout
cas les déterminants sont très
différents mais du scénario haut que
présenté RTE en 2021 pour ce qui est de
mgaw c'est une baisse de la consommation
mais ça ne veut pas forcément dire et
c'est là toute la clé une baisse des
services énergétiques rendus typiquement
quand on parle de la mobilité électrique
si vous allez vers des euh vous profitez
de l'avènement du véhicule électrique
pour aller vers des véhicules plus
petits vers des modes partager de flotes
de véhicules en milieu urbain là où
c'est possible et facile et et pratique
pour les gens vers du réaménagement du
territoire qui permet plus de report
modal euh moins de dépendance à la
voiture et plus de resserrement des
distances à parcourir en fait vous allez
avoir tout en ayant une forte
augmentation de la consommation
électrique pour la mobilité vous allez
avoir une euh une une une modération de
cette hausse par rapport à des scénarios
qui euh se contentent d'électrifier les
véhicules tels qu'aujourd'hui et c'est
c'est vraiment toute la clé comme je le
dis de la maîtrise de l'électrification
c'est d'inclure ces transformations
structurel merci alors euh pour revenir
à RTE euh au départ euh merci merci euh
pour pour toutes les précisions que vous
avez apporté euh à la qualité de vos
travaux je n'en doute pas alors moi j'ai
j'avais jusqu'à présent que la synthèse
donc j'ai vu que si on voulait avoir
d'autres scénarios il fallait aussi
aller dans le détail puisqueil y a un
scénario 6040 qui a été qui a été
regardé c'est vrai que notre souhait en
tout cas moi en tant que rapporteur de
cette commission d'enquête ça serait de
pouvoir vous demander le scénario 70
300 est-ce que il est facile à établir
est-ce qu'il va prendre du temps est-ce
que dans le cadre des 6 mois que l'on a
devant nous est-ce que c'est jouable ou
pas moi c'est ser sera une première
question question après j'ai bien
compris que vous faisz à la fois des
prévisions mais aussi des projections ce
qui est quand même deux choses
différentes hein bien différente que
vous preniez pas position mais est-ce
que vous avez un scénario un peu
privilégié qui vous semblerait le plus
réaliste parce que finalement on
s'aperçoit que effectivement on a on a
baissé plutôt notre consommation
d'ailleurs d'énergie globale quand on
regarde avec l'agence international de
l'énergie on voit que on a quand même
une croissance économique pendant cette
période là moins que celle qui était
dans les années 70 80 mais on a quand
même une croissance économique et on a
une baisse de la consommation d'énergie
ce qui va à l'encontre de ce que dit
Jean covissi d'ailleurs puisque j'ai
assisté à des exposés de Jan covissi qui
regarde la le parallélisme des des des
courbes entre la croissance économique
et la consommation d'énergie ce qui
montre quand même que c'est pas
complètement et notamment dans les
économies développées parce que je pense
que son son raisonnement vaut pour
l'économie mondiale avec la Chine l'Inde
et d'autres pays et pas forcément
uniquement avec les pays développés mais
vous pouvez peut-être me confirmer cela
mais alors moi effectivement j'aimerais
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur verin là vous nous précisez un
petit peu si vous avez un scénario qui
vous semble plus réaliste notamment dans
dans les prévisions et si la croissance
que vous anticipez d'ici 2050 pour vous
elle est linéaire parce que je ne pense
pas mais et et si euh elle n'est pas
linéaire euh qu quelle forme va-t-elle
prendre et parce que c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important aussi euh
quand on regarde ces ces ces prévisions
de consommation euh de savoir se dire
bah si c'est 40 % on prend 2 % par an et
en 20 ans on a pris no 40 % ou est-ce
que l'inversion de la courbe va être un
peu lente au départ et va s'accélérer
par la suite ce que je je pense plus
logique et est-ce que c'est bien ça que
vous avez intégré dans dans vos vos dans
vos prévisions ou
pas voilà alors sur l'agence
internationale
l'énergie j'ai eu le sentiment que vous
mettiez un petit peu moins d'importance
sur l'hydrogène quoi sur la consommation
électrique liée à l'hydrogène parce que
vous y croyez peut-être moins parce que
peut-être que moins de pays se lancec
dans ce dans cette direction là je sais
pas quoi vous peut-être nous préciser
cela voilà les questions que j'ai pour
ouvrir le débat avec les collègues
ensuite
je vous laisse répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur ensuite on passe la la parole
à nos collègues merci
d'avance merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors je je crains de vous décevoir nous
avons pas de scénario
favoris ça nous est d'ailleurs
institutionnellement interdit
et en réalité ces scénarios quand on
regarde ceux sur 2050 il correspondent à
des Frances qui sont très différentes
euh l'objectif c'est vraiment de les
documenter et c'est pour ça que dans les
futurs an 2050 bien évidemment on les
documente techniquement on a une analyse
sur leur résilience hein comment
vont-ils se comporter dans un monde avec
une élévation des températur d' c'est
c'est c'est un sujet complexe parce que
les le changement climatique va pas
avoir le même effet sur le nucléaire les
les les les éoliennes les panneaux
solaires les barrages les barrages
hydrauliques
en matière de de probabilité ce qui est
certain c'est que en ce moment on
assiste à une forme de déconnexion entre
ce qu'on voit dans la consommation qui
est une consommation qui a baissé et qui
ne donne pas de signal de très court
terme de reprise et ce que ce que
devrait être l'évolution de la
consommation d'électricité pour
atteindre nos objectifs ça montre
malheureusement que nos objectifs vont
être difficiles à atteindre voilà c'est
ça que ça montre est-ce que ça veut dire
que il faut renoncer à atteindre nos
objectifs ça je ne pense pas parce que
que en réalité cette dépendance aux
énergies fossiles en plus d'être un
problème climatique qui nous concerne et
nous quand j'ai passé mes 5 7 dernières
années les yeux rivés dans ces courbes
et dans la projection du changement
climatique c'est quand même extrêmement
inquiétant mais en plus c'est un
problème de nature économique pour notre
pour notre pays donc donc je pense qu'il
est souhaitable d'essayer de se diriger
vers ces scénarios de de sortie des
énergies fossiles et transition
énergétique effectivement ça montre que
que que c'est difficile cela dit il y a
un peu un effet de trompelœil que comme
la consommation d'électricité a beaucoup
baissé le
pourcentage d'augmentation nécessaire
apparaît plus important qu'il ne
l'aurait été il y a quelques
années est-ce que la croissance de la
consommation d'électricité pour
atteindre lesobjectif sera linéaire non
je ne pense
pas il peut y avoir effectivement une
forme d'accélération dans la deuxième
partie de la décennie 2020 et peut-être
même plutôt vers la fin de la deuxème
partie de la décennnie quand on voit le
temps nécessaire entre la prise de
décision publique les décisions
industrielles et la mise en œuvre des
différents moyens donc par exemple on
décide de réindustrialiser vous avez des
industriels qui prennent des décisions
le moment où leurs usines concrètement
consommeront de
l'électricité ça va pas être en 2024
2025 vous pensez que ça pourrait se
sentir avant 2030 quandme oui ça peut se
sentir de façon sensible moi j'aurais
dit plutôt à peu après mais quand on
regarde les les perspectives quand on
regarde ce que les industriels nous
demandent parce qu'en plus on a des
demandes concrètes qui est de de
connexion à notre réseau dans les zones
de dkererque de fosse ou du Havre
port-gérôme par exemple on a des
demandes de connexion qui semble assez
ferme pour 2028 2029 2030 il y a même
des industriels qui veulent arriver
avant ce qui est ce qui est assez
ambitieux en tout cas nous on fait tout
pour que le réseau soit pas un frein
pour le moment où ces industriels seront
présents en fait euh cette question de
la la linéarité de l'augmentation de la
consommation d'électricité elle est
vraiment très importante parce que ce
qui ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années c'est que c'est l'intégration par
tous les organismes en charge de faire
de la prévision de la prospective de
l'objectif de 2030 le - 55 % net et
c'est celui-là qui conduit à devoir
faire une accélération très importante
alors que dans les scénarios y compris
ceux des futurs énergtiques 2050 qui
n'intégrai pas le le 55 % net la
l'augmentation était beaucoup plus
dispers dans le temps donc là on a un
effet qui est lié à l'objectif qu'on
s'est donné si on considère
effectivement 2020 c'est la décennie clé
pour le climat et qui donc faut
accélérer et avoir des résultats
concrets desè 2030 mais en fait il faut
accélérer et donc ça nous confronte C
scénari nous confrontte à la difficulté
de le faire et enfin monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez m'ave posé une
question sur les scénarios 70 30 60 40
donc je suppose que 60 le 70 des référen
au pourcentage pour le nucléaire voilà
euh alors là encore un point important
en réalité le pourcentage de tel ou tel
part d'énergie joue un rôle relativement
faible dans nos scénario parce qu'en
fait c'est 70 % de quoi 70 % de
nucléaire oui oui de production mais si
c'est 70 % de la production en 2025 2030
c'est pas du tout pareil que 70 % de la
production en 2050 en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que la part du
nucléaire baisse et va continuer de
baisser mécaniquement dans notre
production d'électricité tout simplement
parce que en fait les renouvelables
peuvent sêtre déployés plus rapidement
donc en fait le dénominateur de la
fraction va juste croître ENF c'est un
effet totalement mécanique même sans
action publique particulière vous
n'aurez vous ne conserverez pas
durablement le pourcentage
actuel après nous avons bien testé dans
les futurs analétiques 2050 un scénario
qui est le n03 sobriété à 60 % de part
du nucléaire et 40 % de part des
renouvelables ce qui me permet de dire
qu'effectivement les futurs 2050 ne sont
pas fondés sur une limitation à priori
de la part du nucléaire ni même sur une
limitation à priori de la part des
énergies renouvelables et on a la
capacité alors la question est de savoir
en combien de temps de tester d'autres
scénarios que ceux que nous avons testé
dans les futurs étiques 2050 le problème
est plutôt de le faire dans de bonnes
conditions temporelles donc là si la
commission d'enquête n'a que quelques
mois c'est pas forcément facile mais il
faut aussi que j'en discute avec mes
équipes voilà sur sur les sur les les
réponses que je pouvais faire oui une
dernière sur
l'hydrogène en matière de si vous
regardez ce qu'on écrit dans nos
rapports depuis quelques années en fait
en réalité on n pas beaucoup changé
d'avis sur un certain nombre de sujets
il y en a un qui est particulier à
regarder c'est l'hydrogène parce que il
y a une
alternance de de cycle d'euphorie et de
de négation de la poten alité de ce
vecteur ce qu'on a dit dans ce rapport
c'est que créer exnilo un système de
production de distribution d'hydrogène
bacarbone c'est l'un des plus grands
défis de la
stratégie française et d'ailleurs un des
plus grand défi de la stratégie
européenne qui dans certains pays met
encore plus l'accent qu'en France sur
l'hydrogène ce que nous voyons c'est que
pour produire de l'hydrogène et pour le
produire de manière compétitive il faut
donc de l'électricité bon marché qu'en
fait on a quand même à financer beaucoup
chose sur la production d'électricité et
que donc l'économie de l'hydrogène va
dépendre de ces conditions
là de la même
façon dans les différents scénarios vous
avez pu voir apparaître récemment des
perspectives de déploiement des
électrocarburants il y a encore quelques
années le secteur aérien n'avait pas une
feuille de route très claire sur sa
stratégie de décarbonation puis ensuite
il a privilégié d'utiliser
des vecteurs venant de la biomasse
aujourd'hui comme peut-être un point de
désaccord avec Negawatt comme en réalité
les les les l'évolution de la du débat
sur le multiénergie nous a plutôt
conduit ces derniers temps à évaluer à
la hausse la par relative de
l'électricité par rapport à la biomasse
un grand nombre de transporteurs aériens
sont venus nous voir et ont dit
peut-être qu'on va pas avoir assez de
biomasse donc on va faire référence on
va peut-être utiliser des
électrocarburant
ça si on projette
c'est les consommations d'électricité
qu'il faudrait pour produire ces
électrocarburants sans changement de la
trajectoire projeté sur l'évolution du
trafic aérien les quantités à terme sont
très importantes si elles sont produites
si ces électrocarburants étaient
produits en France les quantités
d'électricité nécessaires seraient à
l'horizon 2040 2050 plus importante que
ce que nous avons écrit dans les futurs
énergétiques 2050 la question est de
savoir voir si ces électrocarburants si
jamais les transporteurs aériens
confirment ces choix techniques récents
est-ce qu'ils sont produits en France ou
dans d'autres pays qui ont accès à des
ressources énergétiques abondantes ça je
pense que il y a il y a match du point
de vue
économique allez-y
monsieur juste sur la sur la question à
propos de
l'hydrogène effectivement comme je
disais dans dans mon propos introductif
c'est c'est une des grandes incertitudes
de de laie ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de de regarder nos scénarios et
puis de de regarder ce qui se passe
actuellement et notamment moi dans mon
travail ce que je fais c'est que je
regarde les investissements qui vont
dans les différents secteurs
énergétiques et je regarde les
investissements notamment dans
l'hydrogène et en fait on on on voit pas
grand-chose se passer ce qui nous a
amené en fait à réviser nos scénarios
dans le scénario net zéro par exemple on
avait une grande part de l'hydrogène
dans la décarbonation bah des des
camions et du Transport Logistique
routier on l'a pratiquement on l'a enfin
on l' réduit je me souviens plus
exactement de la la proportion mais au
moins de moitié voire
complètement et c'est des transports qui
deviennent électrifiés par batterie
normalement donc c'est c'est une une
part d'hydrogène qui part et on a la
même chose par exemple dans le dans le
chauffage du des bâtiments on avait une
part d'hydrogène avant dans notre
scénario net z0ro là-dessus qu'on a
complètement enlevé et du coup ça donne
une des des des projections d'hydrogène
qui qui restent très très incertaine et
dont on ne voit pas les investissements
se réaliser aujourd'hui pour en assurer
le la la la fourniture
à terme
donc donc voilà c'est c'est c'est le
même mouvement qu'on a vu entre 2021 et
2023 dans nos scénarios notamment sur la
mobilité longue distance liée à
l'hydrogène al nous dans nos scénarios
sur le chauffage il y en avait il y en
avait pas donc on n pas revu à la baisse
mais sur la mobilité longue distance on
a fait le même mouvement que l'Agence
internationale de
l'énergie oui je voudrais juste
commenter sur deux points le premier
c'est c'est l'hydrogène parce que je
pense que c'est c'est une bonne
illustration de la vision que l'on peut
avoir selon qu'on se concentre sur le
système électrique ou selon que on se on
élargit le périmètre une des
particularités de la
modélisation développée par ngawat c'est
de couvrir non seulement les enjeux
énergie et gaz à effet de serre mais
aussi toute l'empreinte en matière
première de notre économie il se trouve
que l'hydrogène c'est aujourd'hui avant
tout une matière première pour des
filières ammoniaques et cetera et que
cet hydrogène pour l'essentiel vient de
craquage de méthane et une source très
importante d'émission de gaz à effet de
ser et donc si on se place non seulement
dans un objectif de neutralité carbone
mais dans un objectif de réduction la
plus rapide possible de nos émissions
parce que je pense que tout le monde
doit avoir conscience que on parle
budget carbone on parle émission cumulé
et c'est bien pour ça queil faut
accélérer y compris d'ici 2030 on est
sur fit 455 les analyses aujourd'hui au
niveau européen montrent que 55 % n'est
même pas suffisant par rapport à un
objectif 1 de5 en budget carbone à
l'échelle européenne et donc il faut
avant tout décarboner cet hydrogène à
vocation industrielle et donc on a du
coup impérativement besoin de développer
un système hydrogène mais il faut pas le
regarder de par son utilité éventuelle
énergétique il faut le regarder
vis-à-vis de cette utilité industrielle
et de fait étant développé il pourra à
terme rendre des service dans le domaine
de l'énergie mais orienté dès qu'on
développe ce système l'hydrogène vers
des utilisation énergétique là où on
pourrait trouver d'autres options c'est
en fait contreproductif par rapport à la
réduction globale des émissions donc
c'est voilà une illustration de la
complexité du système il n'y a pas de
comme source de production d'hydrogène
que ce que vous citez il y a pas que le
craquage du méthane il il y a quand même
même si les rendements une question de
rendement qui se pose il y a a il y a
des façons propre de produire alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement le craquage du méthane
j'ai pas le chiffre en tête il me semble
que au niveau mondial c'est de l'ordre
de 90 % mais je je peux me me tromper
sur ce point et c'est une source très
importante d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre on sait évidemment faire de
l'hydrogène par électrolyse et c'est ça
qu'il faut développer pour mettre
derrière de l'électricité décarboné mais
ce développement il est à la fois
nécessaire mais il est indispensable de
l'orienter d'abord vers les usages
matière plutôt que que énergie la
deuxième chose que que je voulais juste
pointer beaucoup plus rapidement c'est
que cet objectif fit for 55 et cette
accélération à 2030 2035 est précisément
ce qui met en tension notre trajectoire
électrique parce que activer ou non le
levier nucléaire avec de nouveaux
réacteurs c'est un objet de débat mais
c'est un objet de débat qui dans tous
les cas ne portera des fruits dans un
sens ou dans l'autre qu'au-delà de 2035
et donc d'ici 2035 si on veut miser sur
l'électrification en fait il y a pas 36
solutions soit ça veut dire aller
beaucoup plus vite qu'on le fait
aujourd'hui sur les énergies
renouvelables soit ça veut dire
maîtriser découpler les usages
l'augmentation des usages électriques de
l'augmentation de la consommation
électrique autant que possible en
mettant en œuvre de la sobriété et de
l'efficacité et on a très peu évoqué le
plan de sobriété mais negawat avait
produit pour ce plan une cinquantaine de
propositions qui montrre qu'on peut
réduire par des gestes simples comme
éteindre les système de ventilation dans
les logements tertiaires quand ils ne
sont pas occupés de plusieurs dizaines
de terraw nos consommations sans porter
atteinte à au bien-être et au confort ou
à la liberté des individus donc ça c'est
un potentiel qu'il faut aller chercher
rapidement merci Monsieur Je je
reviendrai sur le point dernier que vous
venez d'évoquer mais je voudrais passer
la parole à à mes collègues s'il
souhaite poser des questions Alexandre
Wii
oui merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président montoogé merci à tous pour
pour vos exposés moi j'ai trois petites
questions la première c'est pour pour
RTE en novembre 2022 vous aviez
documenté un risque sur le réseau
électrique d'une de blackout enfin de
coupure générale et donc potentiellement
le fait que pendant l'hiver il pourrait
y avoir des mesures à prendre pour que
les choses se passent bien en même ant
vousc dans vos vos perspectives donc ce
faitl était lié au retard pris sur le
rallumage des réacteurs nucléaires et
cetera mais est-ce que dans avec ce que
vous documentez comme hausse de la
consommation électrique sur le risque de
blackout dans les années à venir comment
vous l'évaluez c'estàdire queil y a un
élément conjoncturel qui était le non
rémarrage des réacteurs mais est-ce que
globalement vous imaginer des
risques liés au changement de la
composition du mix au changement
à la hausse de la consommation qui
pourrait qui pourrait expliquer voilà
des des enfin comment vous évaluez ça en
terme de de risque sur la livraison qui
peut qui peut avoir lieu dans dans les
prochaines années sur sur ce sujet là ça
c'était ma ma première question ma
deuxième question elle porte davantage
sur comment vous comment vous gérez la
sensibilité de vos modèles à
l'efficacité de la politique publique je
je prends un exemple simple qui est très
sectoriel mais pour expliquer ce que je
veux dire euh ma prime renve lorsqu'on
en fait l'audit on constate que c'est
dur enfin que hein c'est c'est pas
terrible euh en terme de d'efficacité
sur ce que ça permet de de réaliser donc
comment vous travaillez je prends un
exemple simple les les les les
rénovations complètes des logements qui
sont celles qui permettent le plus
d'économie d'énergie elles ont une part
très faible je regardais le rapport de B
pierre ce matin je crois que c'est moins
de 10 % des dossiers et donc comment
vous arrivez comment vous travaillez ça
est-ce que vous révisez les choses
progressivement les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs sur sur sur ces sujets là
pour pour affiner vos modèles et quel
est le degré de sensibilité j'entends
que le scénario negawette en fait il est
très sensible au volontarisme politique
parce que il nécessite vous l'avez dit
vous-même un réaménagement du territoire
une reformulation des habitudes enfin
quelque chose d'assez profond donc je
voulais je voulais savoir ça et troisème
point c'est un sujet qu'on a pas abordé
directement parce qu'il est pas dans le
scope je suis désolé je j'espère ne pas
être trop long mais je je finis
là-dessus pas exactement dans le scope
mais c'est là pour le coup pour pour RTE
sur les aspects de coût euh le scénario
6040 le scénario N3 N2 N1 et
cetera la capillarité du réseau
j'imagine qu'elle a des cons donc la
part des renouvelables elle a une
conséquence sur la capillarité du réseau
est-ce que vous réévaluer les choses
est-ce que les choses sont bien précises
aujourd'hui dans vos têtes sur ce que ça
coûte et est-ce que du coup non pas un
scénario préférentiel mais est-ce que
vous avez votre scénario le moins cher
le plus cher le voilà est-ce que ça
c'est c'est c'est clairement établi et
est-ce que ça ça peut être exprimé voilà
merci monsieur le Président y a-t-il
d'autres questions on va les prendre
toutes Fabien Fabien
genunet merci président oui peut-être
pour compléter ce que vient de dire mon
collègue quelle est la sensibilité de
vos scénarios à la à la notion de prix
effectivement on est un peu conditionné
par les auditions que nous avons eu hier
on a beaucoup parlé de la formation du
prix et finalement pendant la crise
qu'on a vécu l'année dernière au-delà de
tout ce qu'on a pu dire sur sur la
nécessité de changer les choses pour
sauver la planète le climat et cetera ce
qui a vraiment fait bouger la
consommation c'est avant tout le prix
c'est quand le prix a commencé à monter
la consommation a baissé donc comment
vous anticipez cela parce que avec tout
ce que vous nous expliquez avec les
investissements qui sont nécessaires ça
va nécessairement avoir des conséquences
sur le prix et donc comment vous
intégrez cette données dans vos dans vos
modèles et puis ensuite à
la à vous entendre je je me disais
mais si on imagine que le prix bas de
l'énergie peut induire plus de
[Musique]
développement qui est le contrraire de
ce que je viens de
dire est-ce que il y aura un autre
scénario où un pays comme la France
pourrait finalement se dire au-delà de
tous les scénaris qu'on me propose je
développe une capacité de production
pour avoir plus d'énergie disponible
pour faire baisser les prix et en cela
je vais faire venir de l'activité sur
mon sol dans la concurrence entre les
pays et donc ce c'est vrai qu'il y a pas
grand monde qui évoque cela puisqu'on a
perdu un peu tout espoir on parle de
réindustrialisation mais pour compenser
ce qu'on a perdu est-ce qu'on pourrait
être encore plus volontariste et est-ce
que vous prenez ce ce type de de de
scénario en en considération et comment
vous vous l'évaluez et enfin sur les là
c'est plutôt le béocien qui vous demande
un peu
d'aide sur effectivement une entreprise
selon qu'elle est localisée en Chine ou
ou en France pour produire la même chose
comment dans tous vos calculs en
particulier internationaux vous prenez
en compte la les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à qui vous les attribuez
et comment
vous tenez compte de ces arbitrages là
il y a il y a déjà pas mal de questions
là je vous propose d'essayer d'y
répondre parce que si on rajoute les les
autres ça va être compliqué je redonne
évidemment la parole après à mes à mes à
mes collègues allez-y en essayant de pas
faire des tunnels trop
long je vais essayer monsieur le
Président
euh novembre
2022 pour répondre monsieur le sénateur
à votre première question
euh la situation en France est la
suivante le parc nucléaire
produit beaucoup moins que ce qui qu'une
production de nominale puisque'en 2022
le parc nucléaire a PR 279 TWh on parle
d'un parc qui produisait 400 TWh il y a
quelques
années la France vit
euh une sécheresse en 2022 la production
hydraulique a été la plus faible depuis
1976 en France et à ce moment précis le
gaz est au plus haut donc dans ces
circonstances ce qui a permis à nos
concitoyens d'avoir euh de l'électricité
c'est deux choses importantes une baisse
de la
consommation assez structurante et
l'excellent fonctionnement du système
d'échange interconnecté en Europe qui a
fonctionné
parfaitement
euh est-ce que quand on regarde ça
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit ça nous dit
qu'en
fait dans le système tel qu'il était les
deux grands facteurs de risque c'était
la grande vague de froid mais alors la
grande vague de froid c'est c'est une
vraie question pour le dimensionnement
du système parce queavevec le
réchauffement climatique elle devient de
moins en moins probable mais elle peut
encore exister donc ça parfait parfaite
question pour le le dimensionnement du
système doit-on se couvrir contre un
événement qui arrive une fois tous les
10 ans la réponse est oui une fois tous
les 20 ans une fois tous les 100 ans ça
coûte cher de se couvrir contre un
événement qui arrive une fois tous les
100 ans pour autant c'est une bonne
question de dimensionnement et puis
l'autre l'autre événement qui pouvait
stresser le système c'est celui qui est
arrivé en 2022 c'est une indisponibilité
simultanée d'un grand nombre de
réacteurs nucléaires à l'avenir les
modal les les la sensibilité du système
va évoluer ce qui va devenir plus
important c'est les moments où il fera
froid qui sont corrélés à une absence de
vent sur la plaque européenne en moyenne
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dans tous
nos scénarios le l'évaluation du risque
ne change pas par rapport il y a 10 20
ans c'est le même volume de risque sauf
que il arrivera pas au même moment vous
aurez des épisodes où il fait froid et
où le système de que le système de 2010
ne savait pas passer qui seront passés
sans aucun problème en 2030 vous aurez
par contre des situations qui ne
posaient pas de difficultés
particulières en 2010 et qui pourront
être plus tendu à l'avenir mais en
volume de risque ce sera pareil et ça
c'est précisément documenté dans nos
scénarios j'en profite pour dire qu'en
réalité nous sommes en train de sortir
les volets techniques spécifique de
notre analyse de septembre qu'il reste à
sortir celle sur les coups celle sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement celle sur
l'hydrogène et celle sur le
bâtiment par rapport à la seconde
question que vous m'avez posé ça fait
pas mal mais c'est c'est mais et puis à
chaque fois que je viens dans dans faire
plancher devant vous je ressors en
général avec d'autres variantes à
analyser donc bon ça alimente ça
alimente les
rapports pour regarder la
sensibilité à efficacité de la politique
publique en fait on fait des stress
tests paramètres par paramètres et
l'objectif de ces stress test c'est de
comprendre si le si l'échec de tel ou
tel point de notre politique est
dimensionnant ou pas pour la réussite du
scénario alors sur le bâtiment en ce
moment on en a fait beaucoup puisque la
question se posait sur le remplacement
des chaudières à gaz par des pompes à
chaleur et donc on a testé plus ou moins
bonne
rénovation pompe à chaleur plus ou moins
efficace on a tresté énormément de
combinaisons ce qui nous a permis à peu
près de reconstituer tout ce qu'on
entendait
entre ceux qui disent que ça n'a pas
d'impact sur la pointe et ceux qui
disent que ça a un impact énorme sur la
pointe on arrive à peu près à comprendre
comment les uns et les autres ont fait
leurs analyses et qu quelles hypothèses
ils ont prises pour parvenir à 0 ou à 15
GW d'impact sur la pointe et à trouver
une vision qui nous semble la plus
réaliste je
pourrais enfin lorsqu'on sortira le le
chapitre je pourrais le vous vous vous
le vous le présenter euh sur les coûts
du
système dans notre analyse de 2021 nous
avons chiffré les scénarios et donc on
arrive à une conclusion sur le fait que
ce sont les scénarios qui comportent un
réinvestissement dans le parc nucléaire
qui peuvent être les moins coûteux pour
la collectivité sous réserve de
certaines hypothèses sur le coût des
différentes technologies et sur leur
modalités de financement parce qu'en
fait ce qui est déterminant dans le coût
du système à long terme outre le coût
intrinsèque d'un moyen de production
c'est la façon dont on le finance si
jamais l'investissement est vu comme
plus risqué pour un investisseur dans un
marché dans un système privé le coût de
financement augmente et lorsque les
moyens de production mettent 10 ans ou
15 ans à être construit c'est
considérable considérable c'est le
facteur numéro 1 on a fait beaucoup de
de de stress test donc il y en a un qui
qui qui est le moins cher euh après euh
vous avez vu que les écarts de coût
n'étaient pas du simple au double on
était sur des écarts qui étaient qui
étaient plus rapprochés et donc je me
permets de vous renvoyer à ce travail
mais là
encore nous pouvons répondre
ultérieurement à toutes ces questions et
Monsieur monsieur le sénateur pour votre
question sur la sensibilité au
prix alors et et au cou on on
généralement dans les études on regarde
le coût complet pour la collectivité et
pas le prix de l'électricité le prix de
l'électricité il dépend d'énormément de
paramètres de ce que font nos voisins
voilà bon ah bon excusez-moi j'ai pas eu
le temps de visionner
encore le ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la stratégie française basée sur du
nucléaire compétitif actuel et des
énergies renouvelables matures est une
solution qui est compétitive à l'échelle
européenne ça il y a pas de doute la
question du prix elle est différente ça
interroge aussi sur le fonctionnement de
notre système électrique totalement
interconnecté qui fait que en fait les
les la les caractéristiques très
particulières du mix français 93 %
décarboné elle se retrouvent pas dans la
formation du d'un prix qui est européen
voilà mais sur le coup on peut vous dire
qu'avec cette stratégie là en théorie on
a une bonne compétitivité à l'échelle
européenne est-ce que on peut s'en
servir pour
réindustrialiser c'est l'objet du
scénario réindustrialisation profonde de
nos de nos
scénarios on a essayé en dans scénari on
essaie toujours de faire bouger des
curseurs mais en n'allant jamais les
mettre au maximum d'un côté ou de
l'autre parce que si on les met au
maximum en fait vous avez des scénarios
vous arrivez la conclusion que la
consommation d'électricité par exemple
en 2050 elle peut être elle peut varier
du simple au triple je trouve que c'est
on a besoin quand même de resserrer un
peu la fourchette pour que ça puisse
servir au décideur donc sur la
réindustrialisation on a monté le
curseur mais en disant que la
réindustrialisation c'était pas dans le
même type d'industrie que dans les
années 80 90 en réalité souvent les
nouvelles usines qui viennent elles sont
quand même beaucoup plus efficaces
électriquement donc elles conduisent pas
à retrouver les mêmes montants de
consommation d'électricité que ceux
qu'on a connu dans les années
90 on a forcément un certain nombre de
cartes à jouer en matière de
réindustrialisation la question c'est de
savoir à quoi on va affecter
l'électricité qu'on va être capable de
produire probablement on ne peut pas
jouer toutes les cartes et tous les
secteurs mais sur un certain nombre de
secteurs et d'industrie de pointe la
France peut tout à fait être compétitive
pour réindustrialiser et pour finir bien
évidemment quand on fait nos analyses de
d'émission de gaz effet de serre nous Pr
non en cycle de vie donc nous sommes
capables de voir quand on publie des
émissions de des trajectoires
d'émissions de CO2 ce qui se passe si
les panneaux solaires sont fait en Chine
s'ils sont faits en Pologne ou s'ils
sont fait en France on est capable
d'avoir cette
différenciation merci en complément sans
peut-être reprendre tous les thèmes à
moins que vous soyez pas
d'accord non si très très très
rapidement je suis à peu près d'accord
avec tout ce qui vient d'être dit juste
pour vous donner un petit peu de de
précision sur notre façon de
d'incorporer cette sensibilité au au au
à l'efficacité des politiques publiques
nous c'est on fait on fait on fait une
approche un peu on a une appoche
scénario donc qui regarde à long terme
ce qui a besoin d'être fait et on fait
c'est notamment ce sur quoi je travaille
moi-même on regarde beaucoup les
investissements qui sont faits le dans
l'historique et on regarde l'historique
immédia et en fait une fois que nous on
a fait l'historique et que les collègues
qui font le scénario on se on se
regroupe et on essaie de voir bah en
fait entre l'année 2023 et l'année 24 s'
y a un énorme trou on comprend qu'il y a
quelque chose qui va pas et que le
scénario incorpore pas les les résultats
de la politique publique et notamment la
prime renove c'est quelque chose que je
suis assez euh assez d'assez de près sur
les la sensibilité des scénarios au prix
nous les prix on suit donc toute
l'énergie pas seulement l'électricité
euh les prix vont influer sur la demande
totale d'un scénario en général il parce
que le le la demande va se focaliser
vers les prix justement qui sont les
plus intéressants pour cette demande euh
mais à la la fin du scénario on sort je
l'ai pas montré aujourd'hui mais on sort
des des besoins d'investissement pour
atteindre les objectifs de de scénario
et quand on regarde par exemple dans
dans l'électricité on a des on a
pratiquement la moitié des des
investissements qui doivent être fait
dans le réseau à l'échelle mondiale je
parle où les réseaux sont sont peuvent
être moins développés et en tout cas où
les réseaux sont très importants dans le
dans le la possibilité de développer les
les renouvelables et donc ça nous donne
en fait ce besoin d'investissement donne
un une idée du coût total du système
électrique don besoin et sur le la
catéor enfin les émissions et à qui
elles sont elles sont assigné nous on
prend vraiment une approche énergétique
entre guillemets les émissions sont sont
assignées dans le pays qui produit le
bien on fait pas de de de retraitement
ensuite pour savoir où va le bien mais
par contre on a effectivement cette même
cette même analyse de sensibilité sur
Suivant où les industries sont dans
différents scénarios donc
merci oui merci pour pour toutes ces
questions alors rapidement d'abord sur
la la
question du du du risque qu'on a connu
l'hiver dernier alors on l'étudie pas du
tout nous avec la même sensibilité que
que RTE je disais tout à l'heure il y a
je connais peu d'équivalent en fait au
niveau européen et même mondial de la
capacité
probabiliste que que RTE développe mais
justement on a été confronté pour partie
à un risque non probabilisable euh qui
est ce cette aléa de sûreté qui a
conduit de manière totalement imprévue à
l'arrêt d'une quinzaine de réacteurs à
cause du problème de de corrosion sous
contrainte et je veux le le souligner
parce que cet aléa peut se reproduire
d'autant plus si on maintient le parc
nucléaire et qu'on l'expose à des
phénomènes de vieillissement même si la
corrosion sous contrainte elle-même est
une usure mais pas de de vieillissement
et et c'est sans doute au aujourd'hui
l'ALA le
plus le plus dimensionnant pour le
système électrique français voire
européen donc il faut aussi avoir ça ça
en tête euh
sur votre votre remarque sur le
volontarisme politique et l'idée que le
scénario negawat serait plus sensible au
volontarisme ça illustre je pense
complètement ce que je disais sur le
biaet culturel qui consiste à penser que
il y a plus de volontarisme dans des
hypothèses sur la demande qu'il y en a
sur l'offre en fait tous les scénarios
d'atteinte du de la neutralité carbone
comporte une part importante de
volontarisme mais moins vous mettez de
volontarisme sur une partie plus vous en
mettez sur d'autres je dire là le le le
le les le le programme nucléaire tel
qu'il est posé aujourd'hui est un projet
volontariste pour preuve tous les
éléments que le gouvernement est en
train de mettre en place pour pour le
réussir euh le
une forte augmentation des énergies
renouvelables est un projet très
volontariste et la mise en œuvre
d'actions beaucoup plus massive de
d'efficacité énergétique ou de sobriété
structurelle c'est volontarist donc les
questions c'est comment on pose
l'acceptabilité de tout ça en
identifiant tous les éléments dont dont
l'enjeu est cononoui sur l'exemple de la
rénovation thermique du
bâtiment vous vous le savez sans doute
c'est un sujet sur lequel ngawat
travaille depuis depuis longtemps on
l'avait porté dès le Grenel de de
l'environnement en 2007 euh c'est un bon
exemple de
l'aller-retour qui peut exister entre
les scénarios et la réflexion sur les
politiques publiques typiquement nous
dès nos premiers scénarios on a
considéré que c'était un levier
incontournable euh et que quand on
rénovait des bâtiments il fallait les
rénover de façon aussi complète
performante que possible euh ça nous a
amené à réfléchir aux politiques
publiques susceptibles de mettre en uvre
une trajectoire de massification de la
rénovation et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de retour d'expérience sur la formation
de groupement d'artisan pour que l'offre
soit disponible sur des mécanismes de
financement pour que le reste à charge
soit aussi faible que possible voir nul
et on sait que ces outils existent et
donc aujourd'hui on renvoie la balle aux
politiques en fait pour dire comment on
fait évoluer les dispositifs et
l'évolution de la prime
renve il participe d'une certaine
manière aujourd'hui pour aller vers
cette massification mais ça permet à la
fois de dimensionner et de réfléchir et
de travailler en fait concrètement au
politiques et mesure euh sur euh la
question des euh des des coûts pour
finir
euh en passant je réponds juste à la
question sur l'empreinte carbone le
scénario negaw je le disais fait une
modélisation en empreinte et donc
vérifie qu'on est en neutralité carbone
en empreinte mais en 2050 mais sous
réserve évidemment d'hypothèse sur
l'évolution dans le sens que montrait
les scénarios de laiee de l'ensemble du
système mondial évidemment sinon la
seule façon d'être neutre en carbone
c'est de devenir autarsique mais sans
capacité de tout réindustrialisé même si
je voudrais le souligner parce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure monsieur le
rapporteur le scénario negaette est en
opposition des autres scénarios je
voudrais redire qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de convergence que d'opposition et
typiquement sur la réindustrialisation
on a a un fort levier de
réindustrialisation et de loocalisation
dans notre scénario mais de façon
peut-être plus ciblée comme l'évoquait
Thomas verin à l'instant que une
réindustrialisation àou vaa qui du point
de vue économique et écologique ne fait
pas forcément sens sur la question des
coûts donc pour
finir d'abord nous la première le
premier enseignement qu'on tire des
scénarios de RTE c'est que le scénario
dit de sobriété est moins cher que le
scénario sans sobriété en coût complet
en 2050 et qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
certitude sur cet écart de coût que sur
le coût sur lié au au mix électrique
Thomas rappelait que c'est notamment
sensible aux conditions de financement
je voudrais juste signaler ici puisque
c'est l'actualité récente que le coût
auquel sort incle point 2 aujourd'hui et
le double de l'hypothèse maximum que RTE
a considéré dans son rapport en stress
test pour le cûp des nouveaux pr
français donc il y a une réflexion là
aussi à mener mais encore une fois la
sobriété c'est la solution pour que ce
soit pour que le le système globalement
soit le moins cher et quand on raisonne
sur l'impact sur les entreprises ou les
consommateurs pardon mais il ne faut pas
raisonner qu'en prix en fait ce qui
compte pour eux c'est la facture et la
facture c'est le prix unitaire fois le
volume et dans une configuration où vous
devezug AUG monter le prix parce que
vous avez des investissements à faire
dans le système ça rejoint ce que je
disais sur le volontarisme quelle que
soit l'option ce volontarisme vient avec
des investissements ou du soutien public
à des changements de de de structurel de
de comportement plus vous avez
d'investissement à faire plus le coût
unitaire va être élevé et donc plus la
maîtrise de l'impact sur les ménages et
les entreprises passe par une maîtrise
de l'effet volume d'où là encore
l'intérêt de politique d'efficacité et
de
sobriété juste pour finir en fait de ce
point de vue il y a une contradiction
intrinsèque
entre l'idée d'augmenter les capacités
de production pour devenir attractif à
travers des prix bas puisque
l'augmentation des capacités de
production va nécessairement générer des
investissements qui va augmenter les
coûts unitaires donc si là encore si
vous n'associez pas ça à des conditions
d'efficience au sens du rapport entre le
volume d'énergie consommé et la
production économique quelle que soit la
mesure qu'on lui donne vous n'atteindrez
pas l'attractivité que vous
visez merci merci on va poursuivre la
série de de de de questions François
bonau peut-être je te donne la parole
après Victorin
oui merci président euh non une question
rapide c'est par rapport est-ce que vous
avez intégré dans dans dans vos scénaris
euh euh l'impact l'impact du contexte
international je je m'explique euh on
sait que les terres rares sont dans des
[Musique]
pays géopolitiquement compliqué euh on
sait que pour fabriquer les batteries
aujourd'hui euh plus de 50 % euh euh des
mines sont sous sous maîtrise chinoise
leur traitement et leur fabrication à 70
% donc si euh voilà si on sait très bien
que aujourd'hui c'est l'Indopacifique
est une zone de tension sans parler des
autres parties du monde est-ce que vous
intégrez ça parce que au niveau du coûp
de
l'approvisionnement ça ça peut avoir des
conséquences assez assez sérieux sur sur
tout ce qui est mis en place aujourd'hui
merci Victorin je te donne la parole
merci Président je reviens peu en
arrière sur la fiabilité de vos
prévisions et de vos
projections RTE quel est l'écart entre
ce que vous aviez prédit si vous venez
sur un passé récent voir même plus long
euh quelle a été la fiabilité de vos
prévisions pour euh euh
l'IEA vous prenez euh la zone France
Italie Allemagne mais l'interconnexion
est beaucoup plus large que ça est-ce
que en terme de représentativité ce que
vous tirez comme conclusion est vraiment
représentative puisque il y a
l'Allemagne il y a euh l'Espagne
l'Italie le bénéuxe euh bon là c'est
réduit à ça est-ce que euh cet
échantillon là est suffisamment
représentatif pour tirer les conclusions
qui ont des conséquences j'imagine sur
une trajectoire à moyen à court moyen et
euh long terme la 2è euh question c'est
sur la les périodes euh là on on
raisonne donc à long terme 2050 mais euh
les garoates insistent sur aujourd'hui
et
2035 que fait-on euh d'ici là contenu
que la construction de nouvelles
infrastructures ça prend du temps que
fait-on d'ici 2035 si on laisse aller le
scénario aujourd'hui tel qu'il est connu
et pratiqué est-ce que il y a des
chances plus que raisonnable pour que ce
qui s'établira en 2035 c'est plus
d'injection et c'est ce qui est
recherché d'énergie renouvelable mais
couplé avec des centrales de gaz je pose
la question avec une arrièrepensé je
l'avoue euh je sais pas ce qui a été
décidé en taxonomie en tout cas il y a
eu des discussions sur le nucléaire mais
je sais pas sur le gaz qu'est-ce qui a
été décidé si on laisse aller les choses
telles que je crois comprendre
euh quand je dis j'aiun arrièrepensé ça
favorisera si je dis la structuration du
régime électrique allemand
euh est-ce que ce qui en projection
linéaire ce qui se fait aujourd'hui ce
sera pas en 2035 euh au nom d'une d'un
verdissement de certaines énergies avec
beaucoup d'injection de d'énergie
intermittente et ça pose les problèmes
de raccordement au réseau d'accès au
réseau avec l'autorisation de l'Europe
de centrale à à à gaz euh et comment
ensuite sortir de cette imposition de
structure ou de ses préférences de
structure comm dirait François
Pérou voilà
je vous laisse la parole qui veut
la peut-être la je vais commencer alors
sur le sur les impacts internationaux
les tensions sur les les métoc critiques
les batteries et tout ça c'est quelque
chose que l'on étudie de manière de plus
en plus fin àilleur on a une équipe
dédiée à ça on l'incorpore pas ou alors
de manière un peu anecdotique dans nos
scénarios complets on on met juste en
garde on étudie justement la
concentration de production des
métocritiques la concentration des mines
c'est dans c'est dans nos rapports ça
n'influe pas encore sur la réalis la
possibilité de réaliser nos scénarios
euh même si dans les scénarios les plus
ambitieux par exemple on on met l'accent
sur euh sur une part de recyclage par
exemple des des métoc critiques ou des
ou des batteries beaucoup plus
importantes que ce qu'elle né
aujourd'hui et on je je me su je crois
le le chiffre on a 20 % des batteries il
me semble à l'échelle d'ici à 2035 qui
sont produit euh de batterie recyclées
euh c'est pratiquement zéro aujourd'hui
euh mais donc pour répondre de manière
courte on met en garde on nintègre pas
encore dans nos scénarios des ces
risques
géopolitiques actuellement concernant la
question sur les régions groupage des
régions c'est c'est quelque chose d'un
peu arbitraire c'est pas quand on fait
nos scénarios on les fait sur l'énergie
globale donc là on parle d'électricité
effectivement les interconnexions et
tout ça c'est une région qu'on utilise
pour tous les tous les aspects
énergétiques c'était juste le niveau le
plus granulaire qu'on ait pour pour pour
parler de de de
l'électricité effectivement on pourrait
réfléchir à avoir d'autres d'autres
d'autres régions elles sont regroupées
ensuite souvent dans nos analyses quand
on est quand on a besoin de moins de
granularité on parle à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne donc c'est pas du
tout un choix qui est politique ou qui
est qui est lié l'interconnexion
euh sur votre question sur le sur le sur
le mix et sur
le l'intermittence effectivement alors
déjà nous on dans nos scénarios on
insiste et je l'ai déjà mentionné mais
on insiste énormément sur le les besoins
d'investissement maintenant pour pouvoir
accommoder un mix différent en 2035 et
quand on parle par exemple des réseaux
les réseaux c'est les investissements
sont très très longs et encore une fois
le réseau a besoin d'être disponible
avant le commencement des projets de
d'intégration de renouvelable et donc
c'est très très important que les les
réseaux soient dimensionnés de manière
suffisante et a apprprié pour intégrer
le un mix qui qui qui change sur les
centrales à gaz alors je vais peut-être
vous choquer mais nous dans l' dans nos
scénarios le des centrales à gaz qui
sont utilisés de manière très
flexible de manière beaucoup avec un
facteur de charge beaucoup plus petit
que ce qu'on voit actuellement pour
accommoder plus de renouvelable c'est
pas quelque chose qui est
forcément discordant avec lateinte d'un
scénar net zé donc on on a on a encore
effectivement des centrales à gaz mais
qui sont utilisés à des à des facteurs
de charge beaucoup plus faible que ce
qu'on que ce qu'on voit actuellement et
si si ça permet justement l'intégration
de plus de renouvelabl alors ça ça
rentre dans les dans les cases de no de
nos
scénarios qu vous dites les facteurs de
charge c'estd la puissance non c'est
l'utilisation en fait l'utilisation du
de de de la centraleaccord si elle
tourne à si elle tourne à 5 % pour
accommoder pour c'est d'accord
ouais je vais je vais poursuivre en
commençant par la la question
effectivement des des des des ressources
des ressources matérielles les terrar ou
les les les métaux comme le il faudrait
parler du cuivre pour l'électrification
ou ou le
lithium c'est c'est quelque chose merci
pour cette question parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on a regardé
de près dans dans dans dans notre
scénario en lien avec cette modélisation
de de l'empreinte matière de de
l'économie française et on s'est donné
dans notre scénario comme règle pour
dimensionner les différentes actions de
rester sous en en consommation cumulée
de ces ressources sous 1 % des réserves
mondiales prouvé en cumule d'ici 2050 ce
qui nous semble être le bon
dimensionnement de de de de de d'une
trajectoire qui ne va pas augmenter euh
de façon draisonnable la pression
extractive
euh c'est un critère que l'on tient sur
à peu près tous les tous les tous les
métaux et j'en profite pour dire qu'il y
a pas de sujet de terre rare particulier
ou très peu sur sur les les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables et que de notre
point de vue il y a pas de sujet
critique sur des Mét criritiques
spécifiquement liés au développement des
renouvelables euh quand on le projette
dans l'ensemble de la consommation de de
notre économie mais effectivement il y a
des sujets sur lesquels on peut être
tangant de ce critère et c'est le cas
pour le lithium c'estàd que dans notre
scénario alors que l'on intègre
différentes hypothèses de sobriété de
d'efficacité au sens taille des
véhicules et cetera tel que je l'ai
évoqué on s'approche de ces 1 % des
réserves mondiales en consommation
cumulée et quand vous n'intégrez pas ça
bah vous les dépassez allègrement le
secrétariat général de la planification
écologique avait fait état en juin
dernier dans le cadre de ces travaux
hein c'est pas les travaux finalisés et
stabilisés mais d'une trajectoire qui
avec l'augmentation de la mobilité
électrique conduisait à ce que la France
ait besoin en 2030 de 5 % de la
production mondiale de lithium c'est
voilà à la fois quelque chose qui nous
semble pas satisfaisant du point de vue
éthique mais qui de plus ne nous semble
pas réaliste du point de vue voilà du
point de vue de de la mise en œuvre donc
ce critère est vraiment important à
prendre en compte et on y travaille
davantage aujourd'hui dans dans le cadre
de de nouveaux projets sur
les l'enjeu lié à la tension que
j'évoquaé à
2035 au au recours au renouvelable et au
risque de recours au gaz alors d'abord
il y a effectivement dans le système
électrique à long terme dans la mesure
où on remplace ce qui en fait le cœur
aujourd'hui même si on le voit moins
d'une perspective française c'est-à-dire
les centrales thermiques
pilotables par d'autres moyens qui ont
soit vocation à fonctionner plutôt en
base c'est le nucléaire soit qui
présente une variabilité prévisible mais
non mais non pilotable c'est les
renouvelables il y a besoin quand même
de garder un petit talon de centrale
thermique et effectivement dans des
conditions de de d'usage de facteur de
charge très différents d'aujourd'hui ce
qui pose la question du modèle
économique et surtout alimenter à terme
avec du gaz qui lui est d'origine
renouvelable pour pour les objectifs de
de décarbonation mais il est
indispensable effectivement si on veut
tenir les budgets carbones que
l'évolution à court terme ne n'ouvre pas
la porte à plus de centrale gaz et donc
ça ça veut dire
enc maîtriser le rythme de
transformation du système et là encore
la seule clé dont on dispose en tout cas
à l'horizon 2030 2035 pour le faire
c'est les actions sété
d'efficacité
je pour
terminer par rapport à votre question
monsieur le sénateur fiabilité des
prévisions bah on est pas si je reprends
les les trajectoires de 2016 2017 on est
plutôt en
dessous euh c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on
est on est dans le faisceau mais on est
en dessous de celle qui nous semblait
être la trajectoire de référence donc ça
veut dire que la consommation
d'électricité a baissé et même plus
rapidement alors je pense que c'est
quand même un effet qui est lié à la
crise c'estàdire que sinon on serait
hors crise ça aurait baissé mais quand
même moins rapidement mais mais
réellement je je je réitère ma
conclusion je dirais que malheureusement
ce que montrai les trajectoires de 2010
c'est que la France n'avait pas de
stratégie de
transition de sortie des énergies
fossiles et que donc comme elle avait
déjà non pas une stratégie mais une
dynamique industrielle de remplacement
des matériels non efficaces par des
matériels plus efficaces et bien la
consommation d'électricité à baissé et
ensuite la crise économique et
énergétique a renforcé ce mouvement
baissier euh mais mais mes collègues on
ont parlé du du contexte international
je je mets l'accent sur un de nos
scénarios récent qui s'appelle
mondialisation contrariée où justement
on a voulu se confronter à un monde
durablement adverse du point de vue
géopolitique
et conflictuel et compétitif pour
l'accès aux ressources alors de la même
façon c'est c'est pas
tellement c'est pas il y a pas tellement
un monde diichotomique entre terre RAR
ou pas de terre rare et d'ailleurs je
m'aperçois que des fois on parle
beaucoup des terres rares alors qu'en
fait le pétrole et le gaz ils viennent
de monde d'un monde qui est également
pas très amical hein souvent d'un point
de vue géopolitique euh nous notre notre
analyse de 2021 mettait l'accent on
avaité 18 métaux et matériaux ça mettait
l'accent sur le sur le cobalt le nickel
le lithium et le cuivre qui était ceux à
surveiller et dans ce scénario
mondialisation contrarié ce qu'on
s'aperçoit c'est que le triptique
recyclage sobriété relocalisation de la
chaîne de valeur est quand même très
important pour faire baisser les
consommation d'un certain nombre de ces
de de de ces matières notamment cobalt
et nickel on voit bien qu'un scénario
sobriété ça peut changer beaucoup les
besoins pour les batteries des véhicules
électriques d'ailleurs pas tellement la
question des énergies renouvelables dans
le système électrique mais plutôt les
batteries pour les besoins de
mobilité d'ici 2035 comment fait-on que
peut-on accélérer et bien on peut
accélérer nos efforts d'efficacité
énergétique c'est le premier point du du
rectangle
euh on peut essayer de continuer la
sobriété notamment tout ce qui est
chasse au gaspie qui est le plus facile
la chasse au G c'est pas un changement
de nos modes de vie après bien
évidemment il y a certains scénarios de
sobriété qui poussent les curseurs plus
loin et qui qui qui doivent être débattu
d'un point de vue politique et social
mais je veux dire le CRAN numéro 1 qui
est la chasse au gaspis si certaines
choses peuvent être pérénisées sans sans
perte de sans sans perte de valeur j'en
profite pour dire que j'ai un remord
pour tout à l'heure en fait quand on
regarde quand est-ce que la consommation
d'électricité a a diminué c'est assez
étrange elle a
elle a diminué à l'automne 2022 bon pour
l'industrie on se l'explique bien c'est
l'augmentation des prix pour les
particuliers l'automne 2022 c'est pas le
moment spécifique où les prix ont
augmenté donc vous voyez c'est un
mélange d'effet prix anticipé pour les
augmentations à venir je pense et d'ffit
prix général on va dire inflation
globale qui a probablement poussé les
les Français à un moment où ils
entendaient beaucoup de message de
vigilance à réduire leur consommation
donc oui oui oui c'est voilà euh donc le
déploiement des renouvelables qui peut
tout à fait être accéléré d'ici 2035 ce
sont les source qu'on peut déployer plus
rapidement et retrouver un bon niveau de
production de nos réacteurs nucléaires
parce que si jamais le parc nucléaire
qui a produit 279 TWh en 2022 qui a
produit de l'ordre de 320 TWh en 2023
parvient à remonter à hauteur de 350 360
terwh avec flamandville plus il peut
même aller au-dessus voyez que nous
regagnons instantanément un certain
nombre de Marg de manœuvre et que donc
nous pouvons et ça nous en sommes
certains euh tenir la trajectoire euh
d'électrification et de manière générale
de transition vers les énergies bac
carbone pour atteindre des objectifs
pour
terminer le mix allemand aucun de nos
scénarios ne conduit à avoir la même
performance énergétique que l'agne
personne ne considère que c'est
souhaitable j'ai déjà écrit dans tous
nos rapports qu'en fait le mix de
production d'électricité français
émettait de l'ordre de 10 fois moins que
le mix allemand donc la même les
scénarios avec une part importantes des
énergies renouvelables sont construits
pour ne pas atteindre la performance du
mix allemand c'est-à-dire pour ne pas
réouvrir de central aux charbon ou pour
n'utiliser des centrales à gaz que de
manière extrêmement ponctuelle
j'en profite pour terminer sur ce
chiffre que nous confirmerons la semaine
prochaine puisque nous publierons au
titre de nos missions le bilan
électrique officiel de l'année 2023 la
production d'électricité en 2023 en
France c'est 1,6 mliè de notre
production au charbon le charbon c'est
1,6 MLI notre
production merci
je merci je je voudrais rajouter une une
question le sujet a été évoqué plusieurs
fois au cours de de cette audition et
vous venez de le faire monsieur verink
revenir sur la sur la
sobriété dans dans l'étude la dernière
étude que vous avez publiée le le volume
euh relatif au au gain en sovriété il
est quand même très très significatif
des trois scénarios que vous avez que
vous avez avancé alors il y a il peut y
avoir des raisons comme celles qu'on
vient d'évoquer que vous vzévoquer qui
conduisent effectivement à de la à de la
sobriété moi je voudrais vous poser la
la la la question par rapport et vous
l'avez vous l'avez effleuré le sujet par
rapport euh à à ce ce que la puissance
publique peut
faire en terme de d'indicateurs euh
intégré dans les tarifs ou ou ou ou même
peut-être dans les offres de marché pour
que justement la la la sobriété soit
valorisé
euh c'est comment comment donner des
signes récompenser comment donner des
signes incitatif à travers les
structures tarifaires à travers des des
des obligations peut-être pour des des
offres non non régulées pour
effectivement atteindre ces niveaux de
sobriété voir VO voir les dépasser voilà
est-ce est-ce qu'il y a des réflexions
là-dessus et quel est votre quelles sont
vos positions à cet
égard monsieur le Président vous poser
une question redoutable excusez-moi je
suis là pour ça
oui je vous écoute alors quand on
travail un tout petit point de
méthodologie pas trop lourd mais quand
on fait notre concertation sont
représenté euh tous les spécialistes des
secteurs les électriciens les
spécialistes du gaz les associations de
consommateurs industriel particulier les
ONG les organisations syndicales les
économistes il y a souvent des gens qui
sont pas représentés sont les citoyens
bon alors comment fait-on pour accéder
aux citoyens bah déjà on présente au
représentants du peuple nos scénari la
deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
constitué l'année dernière un panel de
13000 français avec l'tit de sondage
pour tester les hypothèses de nos
scénarios y compris nos scénarios
sobriété pour voir comment ces
hypothèses étaient
reçues bon euh bah ça montre que il y a
certaines choses qui sont tout à fait
accessibles et donc notamment la chasse
au gaspill c'était accessible cétait
accessible et notamment très facilement
accessible pour une partie spécifique de
la de la population nos aînés qui ont
déjà connu des périodes de sobriété ou
de restriction énergétique euh dans dans
dans dans leurs jeunes années mais ce
ces résultats étaient quand même
intéressant parce qu'il montrent que en
fait finalement les leviers qui ont été
activés lors de l'hiver
dernier mieux éteindre les lumières ne
pas chauffer des des surfaces inoccupées
et cetera des choses que les gens
avaient assez largement en tête et les
gens savaient qu'en fait baisser de 1
degr la température du chauffage ça
pouvait être faire vraiment baisser la
consommation d'énergie de manière
générale ensuite les hypothèses des
scénarios de soté plus structurant
semble euh s'opposer quand même à des à
des problématiques de représentation de
ce qui'est une vie souhaitable al
notamment par exemple la part du
logement individuel par rapport à la
part du logement collectif effectivement
dans les scénarios de sobriété on se dit
que plus de densification de l'habitat
ça a des impacts qui sont très
importants pour baisser la consommation
mais quand vous présentez ces hypothèses
à un panel de Français c'est pas
spontanément ce vers quoi il se tourne
faut être très très clair là-dessus euh
il y a alors vous oui on le savait mais
on en a la confirmation chiffré type
d'hypothèse par type d'hypothèse euh
tout ça pour vous dire qu'en fait on a
travaillé ces hypothèses et qu'on on
voit que il y a une catégorie
intermédiaire notamment sur la
rénovation des logements sur le partage
de l'espace sur le changement des
habitudes de mobilité qui est justement
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire que les gens
sont en sont sont hésitants par rapport
à ça et c'est probablement ces hésitants
qu'il faut aller chercher pour insuffler
des habitude et des transformations des
des habitudes de consommation vers du
bac cararbone mais ça c'est juste
changer de type de voiture ou de types
de chauffage ou vers des comportements
qui sont plus sobres du point de vue
économique excusez-moi excusez-moi
justement comment peut-on ma question
aussi comment peut-on aller les chercher
à travers des des des des indicateurs
des signes et des signes de prix parce
que voilà il y a une forme de il peut y
avoir il peut y avoir une forme de
renoncement euh à l'égard de la
consommation dans l'hypothèse voilà de
de de sobriété dans le cadre de sobriété
qu'on évoque oui je je cétait aussi ça
je comprends votre question mais
malheureusement je
je j'essaie de toujours de présenter des
choses qui sont documentés et pas et là
je suis bien en peine de pouvoir vous
présenter une pensée stabilisée sur ce
sujet ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'effectivement la diminution de la
consommation assimilée à de la sobriété
et en partie une réaction au prix est-ce
que c'était le prix réel c'était au
moins le prix projeté par un certain
nombre de nos
concitoyens que quand on les interroge
une partie d'entre eux disent à la fois
qu'ils ont fait un effort mais que cet
effort n'était pas forcément si
difficile à faire mais en fait ça va
beaucoup dépendre de la catégorie de
gens dont on
parle et
que bien évidemment la question de la
tarification de l'électricité euh va
jouer un rôle dans les incitations pour
les gens à être plus ou moins économes
et et peut-être être plus ou moins
économes en fonction des périodes on a
pas forcément besoin qu'ils économisent
de l'électricité tout le temps ou disons
je vais reformuler qu'il y a certains
moments où ça entre guillemets vaut plus
oui voilà qu'à d'autres moments et que
ça il faut probablement apporter
apporter cette cette information mais
voilà ce que voilà ce que ce que je je
pouvais dire sur sur cette question en
tout cas une chose pour pour finir j'ai
animé pendant 2 ans des débats publics
sur la question de nos
scénarios le sujet le plus conflictuel
dans un débat public c'est pas
renouvelable et nucléire c'est la
question de la projection sur la
sobriété et de la perception de l'équité
de ce qui est demandé aux différentes
catégorie de la population toujours
toujours revient une question d'équité
moi je veux bien baisser ma consommation
si je suis sûr que d'autres catégories
de la population font le même type
d'effort en même temps ça revient tout
le le
temps l'élasticité
prixah va dépendre des pays va dépendre
des modè de des modalités de taxation
mais oui oui l'élasticité prix on la
voit sur le
terrain de la sété électrique et dans le
même temps on veut que tout le monde
passe au véhicu éleri donc
ça pas je pense qu'on demande de la
sobriété de manière générale plus un
transfert mais sur cet exemple sa à dire
une une bêtise et vous me corrigerez si
c'est le
cas vont très certainement se mettre en
place des systèmes à partir des
véhicules électrique ou à certains
moments de la de la journée ou de
l'année la l'électricité stockée dans la
dans le véhicule électrique pendant la
nuit par exemple peut être récupéré
remise sur le réseau il peut y avoir des
allés etretours comme ça et ça c'est une
voilà c'est un exemple de contribution
effectivement individuelle à une
problématique plus plus plus plus
nationale et et de manière incitative
quoi bon on n pas encore dans le détail
de tout ça mais c'est c'est c'est quand
même on est quand même un chemin
quoi l'E l'effacement en général c'est
un déplacement
voilà donc neeffacement nous ne
l'assimilons pas dans nos études à une
économie d'énergie on l'assimile à une
flexibilité de la consommation
flexibilité c'est
peut-être monsieur Marignac l'effacement
c'est au final une économie de puissance
mais en tout cas ça peut
l'être merci pour cette question qui est
effectivement très très compliqué la
première réponse qui pourrait être
simple
euh c'est que une tarification
progressive est le meilleur moyen
d'envoyer ce signal euh je dis elle
pourrait être simple parce que ça a déjà
été essayé par le législateur il y a
pratiquement une dizaine d'années je
crois euh et ça n'a pas fonctionné pour
une raison très simple qui est que le
Conseil constitutionnel si je ne dis
toujours pas de bêtises l'a invalidé euh
parce que ça a entraîné une inégalité
devant la loi entre les ménages
qui tributaair du chauffage électrique
et ceux qui ne le sont pas et et c'est
assez logique et peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on saurait différencier
ces facteurs de consommation puisqu'on a
des nouveaux outils de compteur
intelligents mais en tout cas évidemment
il faut tenir compte de de ce genre de
problème donc ça reste sans doute une
piste à explorer mais si les conditions
permettent aujourd'hui en tout cas d'une
manière générale la logique de tarif
progressive est évidemment très positive
de ce point de vuel peut-être un
deuxième élément c'est tout ce qu'on
appelle les Esco c'estàd c'est des
sociétés qui se rémunèent alors c'est
soit directement le fournisseur
d'énergie he soit des sociétés tierces
qui se rémunère sur les économies
d'énergie dans lesquelles elles
accompagnent les particuliers ou les
entreprises et donc ça peut-être que
dans les logiques de marché favoriser ce
genre de choses ou favoriser dans un
autre registre mais tout à fait
complémentaire ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les économes de flux je sais
pas si vous identifiez ce cet objet mais
c'est en fait c'est des voilà des des
des des des personnes qui vont chasser
toutes les économies possibles en
sobriété en efficacité sur l'ensemble
des flux à l'échelle par exemple du parc
d'une collectivité et dès lors qu'on est
sur des collectivités de quelques
quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes c'est des postes qui se
rémunèent sur les économies qu'il
génèent aujourd'hui ça existe en tout
cas ça commence à être mis en place dans
les collectivités ça pourrait tout à
fait être mis en place pour des grands
parcs tertières ou pour des parcs
tercières qui mutualisent euh ces
postesl et là aussi il y a peut-être des
des choses à faire et puis voilà au-delà
de ces effets là il y a évidemment tout
l'accompagnement euh toute la
sensibilisation que l'on peut faire
auprès des particuliers et le
gouvernement avait commencé à le faire
euh avec son plan de sobriété avec les
différentes annonces et ça effectivement
même si c'est difficile de le corrélé
d'un effet euh euh conjoncturel de de de
voilà de de tension économique pour les
ménages et surtout pour les entreprises
mais ça a produit des effets euh ça a
permis aussi euh je pense de retrouver
un lien euh dans nos représentations
avec l'énergie hein moi je reste frappé
je recite souvent ça par le fait que on
vit quand même dans un pays où le
gouvernement a dû faire une circulaire
pour rappeler aux commerçants que il
était raisonnable de fermer euh la porte
dans euh des euh
locaux commerciaux que l'on climatise en
été voilà ça ça dit quelque chose de
notre déconnexion avec la réalité
concrète des des consommations d'énergie
donc il y a toute cette
sensibilisation à faire et de ce point
de vue-l il y a aussi peut-être des
signaux clairs à envoyer que les
citoyens quand on les interroge demande
je pense par exemple un truc un peu
iconique qui est les les grands écrans
publicitaires télévisés qui inondent
certains espaces publics comme ceux des
transports collectifs en en région
parisienne euh couper ou en tout cas
réguler la consommation de ces écrans
qui souvent euh je pense à ceux des
transports parisiens ne peuvent pas
éteint être éteints la nuit parce que
ils sont sur le même système électrique
que les systèmes de sécurité donc vous
voyez du point de vue de la trajectoire
électrique ça va pas changer grand-chose
mais euh dans ce que demandent les les
citoyens pour adhérer à un un projet
plus sobre il y a effectivement des
signaux un peu symbolique comme ça à à
envoyer et puis pour finir je vais pas
rentrer dans dans dans le détail du tout
mais cette cette sobriété plus
structurelle
euh ce que montre beaucoup de sondages
ce que montrre beaucoup de conventions
citoyennes ou d'exercices délibératifs
c'est que les citoyens effectivement dès
lors que on les n amène à réfléchir à
cette question ils sont prêts mais à un
certain nombre de conditions la première
c'est d'être accompagné ils refuse
l'idée que c'est juste une histoire de
changement individuel de de comportement
de responsabilité de chacun et cetera
ils veulent être accompagnés il faut
créer des offres et des politiques de
publi de sobriété il demande à disposer
d'alternative euh alors là je vais
prendre un exemple dans la mobilité hein
c'est la la crise des gilets jaunes la
crise des gilets jaunes c'est dans dans
notre lecture d'abord le symptôme d'une
politique d'ébriété énergétique qui a
pas dit son nom autour d'un étalement
périurbain et cetera qui a
progressivement augmenté les distances à
parcourir et la dépendance à la voiture
pour le faire et d'un seul coup on dit
aux gens qu'on a mis progressivement
dans cette situation comme c'est pas
bien du point de vue de notre
consommation d'énergie fossile qui est
évidemment la cible principale de la
lutte contre le changement climatique on
va vous mettre une taxe pour vous
inciter à changer mais voilà il y a pas
d'autres possibilités et cetera donc la
création d'alternative est une condition
clé et la troisème le trisème élément
c'est identifier les cobénéfices les
cobénéfices du point de vue de la santé
des cobénéfices du point de vue du
confort de vie de l'environnement urbain
par exemple si on réduit la taille ou le
nombre des véhicules en plus de les
électrifier en milieu urbain c'est une
réduction de la pression urbaine et de
la de la et de la pollution et donc
quand on met en avant ces éléments là
les citoyens sont je pense beaucoup plus
disposés à adhérer à des politiques de
sobriété bien conduite et restant dans
le domaine de l'intelligence d'usage que
les décideurs politiques ne sont
spontanément prêts à à le
croire merci merci à tous les trois je
vais laisser la parole au rapporteur
pour conclure merci oui on va on va
sarrê éit très bientôt moi j'ai j'ai
juste deux petites questions pour euh
pour RTE
euh tout d'abord tout à l'heure en
répondant sur sur l'évolution des 10
dernières années et vous avez parlé d'un
scénario de
référence euh pour les années 2016-27
vous avez dit on est on est en dessous
de notre scénario de référence donc je
sais pas si ce scénario de référence
existe toujours quoi c'est dans dans je
reviens un peu sur ma question sur le le
la les scénarios privilégiés ou pas donc
si vous en aviez à l'époque peut-être
que vous en avez encore aujourd'hui
voilà
et et dans dans tout ce que vous avez
entendu parce que votre travail est
hyper sérieux en tout cas on a pu le
constater dans votre exposé et dans dans
dans vos travaux quelle est la critique
qui vous a le plus marqué de quel
organismeok qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
vous
a été le plus
reproché
c'est une question assz ouverte mais
enfin il faut que la réponse soit
courte je m'attendais pas à cette
question
sur j'ai fait
référence probablement la trajectoire
numéro 3 de notre bilan prévisionnel de
2017 parce que c'est celle que nous
avions retenu dans le plus de scénarios
de mix en 2017 donc c'est purement
technique c'est qu'en fait quand vous
faites des SC vous croisez une hypothèse
sur le mix et une hypothèse sur la
consommation à l'époque en
2017 on estimait que quatre scénarios
c'était beaucoup et donc on on avait
apparillé un scénario de mix et un
scénario de
consommation maintenant en fait je pense
qu'il faut résister à cet apparillement
à priori parce que j'ai rencontré dans
toute la concertation des gens qui
aimaient la sobriété et le nucléaire en
même temps il voulaient pas être qu'on
dise que le scén nucléaire c'était le
scénario de lesbriétés énergétiqu et
puis j'ai rencontré des gens qui
croyaient à la sobriété et au
renouvelables aussi en même en même
temps et donc j'avais pas de raison de
distinguer à priori de faire un
apparillement entre consommation et
production de cette façon-là de la même
façon si je regarde dans d'autres pays
européens notamment un pays un grand
pays proche de nous quand on traverse un
grand fleuve qui se jette dans la Mer du
Nord euh il y a beaucoup une stratégie
très claire sur le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables mais pas parti
particulièrement sur la sobriété donc il
n'est pas vrai que on peut faire un
apparement facile entre une trajectoire
de consommation et une trajectoire de
production c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans les futurs énergétiques 2050 on a
trois grands scénarios de
consommation référence sobriété et
réindustrialisation profonde bon
référence parce que c'était celui qui
collait le plus à la stratégie nationale
bac carbone et six scénarios de mix donc
quand on les croise ça a fait 18 on
s'est arrêté à 18 on n pas croisé toutes
les variantes entre elles comme je vous
l'ai dit monsieur le sénateur après ce
qu'on essaie de faire c'est faire une
analyse facteur par facteur pour donner
voir ceux qui sont les plus
dimensionnants à contrario et les
distinguer des plus
petits par rapport à votre dernière
question nous avons déjà quand nous
avons
publié on n pas eu en réalité énormément
de critique parce que le travail travil
que nous avons publié était très attendu
et une partie bon des des des réactions
étaient liées au scénario que
proposaient ou que poussaient les uns ou
les autres mais d'un point de vue
méthodologiqueun de vue technique sur
nos scénari les critiques ou les
conseils étaient toujours de de qualité
nous ont pas déstabilisé parce que c'est
déjà un travail qu'on avait cherché à
faire ce qui me semble particulier ce
que ce qui ce qui ce qui me semble pas
euh correspondre du tout à la vérité
c'est d'entendre que nous aurions borné
à priori la part du nucléaire dans ces
scénarios ce n'est pas le cas je suis
sous cement et je vous le dis ça n'est
pas le cas nous avons travaillé avec des
trajectoires de développement des du
nucléire qui été proposé par un certain
nombre d'acteurs nous les avons mis en
consultation nous les avons fait évoluer
à l'issue de la consultation et en
réalité nos trajectoires de 2021
traduisent les différentes projections
qu'il était possible de faire à cette
époque avec sur la base des perspectives
industrielles sur le nucléaire ça ne
veut pas dire que c'est un plafond
d'ordre absolu parce qu'en fait les
prafonds d'ordre absolu ça n'existe pas
et comme ce qui est marqué dans le gros
document si on refait l'analyse plus
tard en fonction de l'évolution de
l'industrie sur le nucléaire et ce
serait vrai aussi sur le renouvelable
les perspectives industrielles peuvent
changer et nous avons eu un excellent
exemple dans cette audition qui était
celui sur l'hydrogène entre ce qu'un
certain nombre d'acteurs de la filière
de l'hydrogène pour ne pas parler que de
celle du nucléaire on pu nous dire entre
2019 et 2021 entre ce que ces acteurs
peuvent dire aujourd'hui entre les
perspectives concrètes d'investissement
que nous voyons aujourd'hui alors je
n'ai j'ai pas la même degré de
profondeur l'analyse que que que T guide
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
parce que moi j'ai pas regardé
concrètement les investissements qui
était fait dans le secteur mais on voit
bien que il y a des vraies incertitudes
sur ces aspects là donc moi ce que je
voudrais dire devant devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est que nous n'avons pas
fait un travail de cadrage à priori au
contraire nous avons cherché à élargir
le plus possible le champ de ce qui
était proposé et c'est un travail que
nous sommes prêts à continuer pour
l'avenir merci j'aurais une une question
complémentaire par rapport au au
nucléaire dans dans votre étude ou vos
études les SMR sont
évoqués comment sont-il in pris en
compte est-ce que est-ce qu'ils sont
intégrés bon la technologie n'étant pas
mature au moment où on parle est-ce
qu'ils sont intégrés dans les hypothèses
de d'électrification des filières
industrielles en particulier première
question et deuxème
question à partir du moment où où la
technologie sera sera disponible mature
industrialisable est-ce que c'est est-ce
qu'on pourrait utiliser des
SMR pour la pointe pour la réponse à la
pointe comme aujourd'hui on utilise des
turbines à
gaz alors
euh dans la concertation 2019 à
2021 le sujet du SMR est arrivé assez
tardivement il est arrivé assez
tardivement parce que les premières
discussions portaient vraiment sur des
réacteurs de grande taille unitair comme
des pr ou des PR2 et c'est seulement
donc dans le scénario
n03 que nous avons proposé un package
sur nucléaire qui consistait en la la
mise en service de 14 nouveaux réacteurs
de type PR2 en la mise en service de 3
GW de SMR et en la prolongation jusqu'à
60 ans en moyenne et pour certains
réacteurs au-delà de 60 ans euh des la
durée de vie d'exploitation des
réacteurs nucléaires actuels ce qui est
en fait le scénario qui permettait avec
une consommation de référence d'arriver
à environ 50 % pour pour la part du
nucléaire dans un monde neutr en carbone
mais à 60 % dans un scénario sobriété
puisque là avec moins de consommation
bah si vous poussez plus le nucléaire
vous avez besoin de moins d'énergie
renouvelable pour boucler
eu le le le le le SMR étant arrivé
tardivement on s'est aussi aperçu qu'il
y avait plusieurs conceptions de ce que
pouvait être le SMR il y a des
propositions de SMR qui sont pas si
small que ça
euh et donc un SMR qui va faire entre
100 et 200 MW avec une paire de SMR
typiquement c'est un une installation de
production qui va avir la taille d'une
centrale à gaz ou la taille d'une
centrale à charbon et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs le marché qui est le plus
visé à l'export pour ce type de filière
parce que dans certains pays le réseau
ne permet pas d'intégrer des pr ils sont
trop gros don alors que un un SMR ça va
être plus facile par rapport au réseau
existant et puis vous avez aussi des des
propositions mais qui semblaient moins
mature quand même à l'époque de SMR très
très petits qui pouvaient s'intégrer
dans un tissu industriel en lien avec
des perspectives de
cogénération on n pas tranché dans les
scénarios entre ces deux modèles parce
que objectivement en 2020- 2021 c'était
trop tôt pour le faire quant à la
possibilité qu'un SMR fasse de la pure
pointe j'avoue à ce stade être un peu
sceptique euh mais
il semblerait que certains de C de ces
réacteurs puissent être plus flexibles
donc qui puisse s'ajuster à la
consommation plus facilement pourquoi
pas la la les besoins de pointe ou
d'ultra pointe ça va être quand même
très particulier he ça va être des
besoins de quelques heures par an je
pense pas que H un réacteur nucléaire
doit fonctionner quand même beaucoup
plus donc je pense que même sous la
forme SMR un réacteur nucléaire ça reste
une une énergie de
base si je peux juste réagir r
rapidement donc donc ça ça redonne de
l'intérêt à au biogaz et cetera
pour on n'a jamais dit que le biogaz
n'avait pas d'intérêt donc le non fait
je m'exprime peut-être mal mais non non
non mais vous c'est
hypothèse pour la pointe pour pour la
pointe les candidats sont euh garder des
centrales fossiles très peu utiliser
donc si jamais dans un scénario net zéro
ça peut passer si ça correspond ouais si
si vous avez de la capture ou si
vraiment c'est quelques heures c'est
quelques heures par an ouais du biogaz
ou des turbine à hydrogène ou des
biocarburants merci juste un Petitot
surès rid arrête après je vous donne la
parole un une question de coût
d'intensité capitalistique qui est
incroyable si on veut juste utiliser les
smmr pour pour réduire la pointe ça n
paraît pas la meilleure
utilisation du et donc dans No scénario
il le développement arrive trop tard
pour être utile dans la décarbonation du
du secteur électrique monsieur Marignac
pour terminer oui quelques éléments
parce que c'est c'est des dossiers que
je suis à travers différents groupes
d'experts auprès de de l'autorité de
sûrté
nucléaire le concept le plus avancé
aujourd'hui c'est newward qui est
effectivement un SMR en France un SMR
relevant plutôt de la première catégorie
qui a évoqué Thomas qui est plutôt une
grosse installation de fois 160 l mgaw
si ma mémoire est bonne
euh un dossier d'option de sûreté a été
déposé auprès de la SN mais on n'est
encore pas à l'avantprjet détaillé euh
il y a c'est c'est un réacteur qui
apporte beaucoup d'innovation du point
de vue de sa sûreté qui reste dans la
filière des réacteurs à préurisé mais
qui vise à beaucoup d'innovation et
beaucoup d'innovation ça veut dire
beaucoup de challenge dans la pour aller
au bout de la démonstration de sûreté et
cetera et donc voilà l'objectif que que
se donne aujourd'hui les porteurs du du
projet d'aboutir à un premier béton en
2030 et à minima tendu euh et de toute
façon leur objectif en tout cas pour ce
modèle est de clairement à l'exportation
euh même si on peut s'interroger si le
projet aboutit sur l'appréciation
couront les Français de l'intérêt
d'aller plus tôt vers ce type de modèle
si il s'avère plus sûr que vers des pr
sous réserve que ce modèle tienne euh
ces objectifs de compétitivité ce qui
n'est pas gagné on a l'exemple récent de
newcale aux États-Unis où le projet
s'est arrêté parce que les les les coûts
les coûts dérivés donc on on on verra ce
que ça donne et après il y a tout tout
l'autre registre qui est celui des ce
qu'on appelle maintenant les xmr pour
tout petit ou micro microréacteurs ou
les Amr parce qu'ils sont advanced euh
et qui revisitent euh pratiquement
toutes les filières nucléaires imaginé
tenté développer sous forme de prototype
dans le passé mais avec l'idée de le
faire en plus petit avec l'idée et c'est
peut-être là qu'il y a des réflexions à
avoir de faire de la cogénération ou en
tout cas de fournir de la chaleur euh
sur des usages industriels typiquement
mais euh sur ces concepts-l aucun n'est
à l'état d'un design technique euh en
soumis à discussion avec l'ASN aucun
n'est en l'état modulaire parce qu'on
parle toujours de réacteur modulaire
mais modulaire ça veut dire qu'on
construit de façon modulaire avec une
usine qui fabrique les modules et là ce
dont on parle ce sera de toute façon des
prototypes et puis surtout on en est
qu'au balbusement des réflexions sur
l'évolution de la réglementation pour
l'adapter à ce type d'objet parce
qu'évidemment ça pose des questions
assez redoutables de
dissémination du risque nucléaire de
dissémination des besoins de trans
transport d'entreposage de déchets de
gestion des déchets de responsabilité
civile de sécurité on va pas mettre un
plouton de gendarmerie devant chaque xmr
comme on le fait aujourd'hui dans nos
centrales et et les réflexions sont
balbuciantes tout ça indique que
vraiment c'est très loin et que d'ici là
le système électrique où les
renouvelables vont de toute façon
continuer à se développer très fortement
trouvera inévitablement d'autres
solutions pour pour pour s'adapter et
encore une fois la question c'est
comment les politiques accompagnent ces
solutions pour qu'ell ne soit pas
contreproductive du point de vue des
coûts ou du point de vue du carbone ok
merci merci à à tous les quatre pour cet
échange ces échanges merci
beaucoup